Okay, diesmal geht das Mikro nicht.
Das würde gebetet werden.
Ich habe gerade übelst fett Eis.
Richtig messig fettes Eis
gefressen.
7 Euro kostet ein Eisbecher mittlerweile.
Früher kam es aber 5 Euro schon teuer vor.
Also früher, vor, keine Ahnung.
3 Jahre.
Richtig, richtig.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, wenn wir gerade schon
bei Stellenanzeigen sind.
Okay, ich gebe zu scheiß Überleitung, weil
das hat mit dem anderen jetzt auch nicht viel zu tun.
Naja, wobei, doch hat es.
In gewisser Weise.
Da wird es ja auch um unsere Gunst geworben.
Ich habe gesehen, es gibt
ein Wahl-O-Mat zur Europawahl
2024. Den können wir auch später machen.
Ich hoffe, diesmal sind die Fragen
nicht so hyperpepega wie in den letzten Wahlen.
Oder vielleicht machen wir das auch zuerst.
Keine Ahnung, mal gucken.
Können wir machen.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Der Markt regelt das.
Kommt da wieder raus.
60?
Na eher 50.
Also, als ich
zum ersten Mal
den Carsten und den Fabian, also den Frazier
im Osten besucht habe.
Von einer Weile her.
Da kostete dort
die Kugel Eis noch 50 Cent.
Im Osten. Bei uns kostete es auch schon
1 Euro.
Nein, ich will definitiv nicht
vor allem bei 17.5.
Und ich vor allem war.
18. Das ist alles verbuggt as fuck.
Ich weiß nicht, was VmWare treibt.
Okay, was?
Da muss man.
Kein Kaffee, was was Prod.com da treibt.
Ich habe gehört, bei uns auf der Arbeit gibt es Stress wegen Prod.com und VmWare.
Ja, die haben tatsächlich auch schon Proxmox evaluiert.
Aber das war nicht Enterprise Business genug für uns.
Wir wollen auf Proxmox umsteigen.
Warum Boxbox zu günstig?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was kostet.
Ich glaube, dass Proxmox in der Standardvariante gar nichts kostet.
Oder?
Weil, da gibt es ja auch ganz viele Homelab-Leute,
die da drauf stehen.
Man kann sich wahrscheinlich irgendeine Business Support-Geschichte kaufen.
Ich habe mich ehrlich gesagt mit den Business Enterprise Finanzierungssachen von Proxmox,
können wir gerade mal kurz gucken, ehrlich gesagt nie beschäftigt.
Hyper-V ganz bestimmt.
Also, ich meine, wenn du Windows-Kisten hast,
wenn du Windows-Kisten laufen lassen willst,
lasse ich mir Hyper-V noch gefallen.
Ich meine, du musst dich da eh nicht aufhören, wenn du Windows-Kisten hast.
Also, muss dich da eh zwangsläufig
mit dem abgrundtiefen Scheiß von Microsoft, was Server angeht, auseinandersetzen.
Also, gegen Desktop-Windows.
Ich benutze – gegen Desktop-Windows sage ich ja gar nichts – hat auch viel Shit.
Aber Server-Windows ist einfach…
Also, wer wirklich ernsthaft Server-Windows benutzt und das feiert,
der hat, weiß ich nicht…
bei dem ist irgendwie dieser 지금, keiner will mal alle Tắm im Schrank haben.
Das meine ich mit voller Überzeugung.
Immer wenn ich irgendwas mit Windows-server sehe,
greife ich mir an den Kopf,
unglaublich dämlich das alles gemacht ist sicherlich auch nicht alles schön
unter linux oder unter bsd aber was windows treibt allein schon wenn ich
diesen komischen windows server setup wie heißt das setup center wie heißt
das ding ich habe wieder vergessen aufgaben planungs assistenz center ihr
wisst was ich meine wenn ich das schon sehr
ja mal gucken mal jetzt kaufen ok jetzt kaufen bei subscription ok was was was
kostet wenn ich brauchst mal vor allem frage ist was kostet box mit der
enterprise lizenz und was kriege ich dafür
servier server manager meine ich ja genau dieses hässliche dinge das ist so
ein guckt euch das an mann wenn ich das schon sehe guckt euch an mann
also
schrott hyper wie auf den notebooks der macht denn sowas wusste gar nicht
dass das da gescheit drauf läuft okay guck mal es gibt community und wenn
für community standard premium support tickets response time ok
business business enterprise business enterprise kostet box box v e premium
subscription eine cpu ja
ja gut ja gut ich wein guck mal unlimited support tickets response time
tour also die leute und das muss ja irgendwie bezahlt werden ja wenn ich mir
das angucke wie viele was weiß ich und 30 kern cpu kisten bei uns da die wir so
eine virtualisierung umgebung ausmacht ich gehe mal davon aus wir haben bestimmt keine ahnung
es gibt dann auch wie gesagt haben wir ja mal diese eine period Unbelievable
ich weiß oftens zwei tippe us oder so das heißt dann würden wir pro jahr eine
million eine million box
naja gut das ist im vergleich zu dem agenten was was mir ford brother klaus
geben und so ja immer noch absolut lächerlich und was wir und was wir für
fremde ausgeben weiß ich nicht aber wasfällig ist das Dinge noch billiger an
Moment, das ist einfach, das ist einfach das mal 4.
Ja, also zu billig kann es nicht sein.
Ist es auf jeden Fall auch ein Standard, was der Unterschied ist.
Okay, die Hälfte, die Standard ist die Hälfte, sind aber auch nur 10 Support-Tickets im Jahr und Dings.
Basic, guck mal, in Basic machen die gar keinen Remote-SSH, gar keinen Remote-Support.
Also ich finde, Remote-Support ist tatsächlich Pflicht, wenn du dir so einen teuren Vertrag kaufst.
Ja, Chat, ich hab letztens super geheime Sachen, was die SAP Cloud angeht, gehört.
Ich hab zwar nix unterschrieben, dass ich das nicht sagen darf, aber ich sag's lieber nicht.
Aber ich sag nur so viel, die SAP Cloud ist nicht unbedingt das, was man auf den ersten Blick denken mag.
Keine Ahnung, wie secret das alles ist. Wie gesagt, ich hab nix unterschrieben, ja.
Musst du ja ein bisschen kecken.
Also ich hab heute schon 7 Kilometer normal durch den Wald gelaufen und vorher eben gerade noch 35 Kilometer Fahrrad gefahren.
Eineinhalb Stunden.
Das war keine allzu große Runde, aber relativ zügig.
Und, aber nicht so, dass ich jetzt übelst im Arsch bin.
Deswegen, eigentlich ganz nice.
Deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, wir streamen jetzt mal eine Runde.
Also, das ist, auf jeden Fall.
Definitiv zu viel für mich daheim, ja.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, man könnte, wenn man's unbedingt möchte, könnte man's machen, aber ich seh den Sinn nicht davon.
Ich mein, ich geb auch im Jahr 180 Euro für mein JetBrains All-Desktop-Package aus.
Das ist Business Enterprise Shit.
Ganz ehrlich, das sieht aus unserer Sicht so aus.
Aber, also.
Ich, ich lässe ja auch immer ganz gerne über SAP und Oracle und sonst was.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass alle, die Oracle und SAP anschaffen, einfach nur dumm sind, greift man zu kurz.
Dummheit ist immer so ein bisschen so das Letzte, was man eigentlich...
Ich mein, es ist oftmals der Fall, ja.
Aber, damit kannst du nichts anfangen, wenn du Dummheit vermutest, ja.
Also, geh ich davon aus, die machen das absichtlich.
Und gerade im SAP-Umfeld ist es halt so, es gibt halt in vielen Sachen oftmals SAP.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Weil, SAP integriert sich am besten mit SAP.
Und deswegen kaufen die Leute dann weiteres SAP.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn du bei größeren Versicherungen und Banken unterwegs bist.
Diese ganzen Wirtschaftsprüferläden omnipräsent sind, ja.
Du hast PwC, EY und wie heißen die anderen Typen da?
Es gibt vier große gibt's da.
Überall, überall kastern die rum.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die da eigentlich alle machen.
Okay, wir haben ein paar Leute tatsächlich von einem der großen vier, zumindest zwei.
Da muss ich sagen, die machen tatsächlich was für ihr Geld.
Wobei die nichts machen, wo ich mir denke, das hat jetzt eigentlich nicht so direkt was mit Wirtschaftsprüfung zu tun.
KPI, die gibt's auch noch, genau.
Das kann sein, mit denen hat das ja nichts zu tun.
Naja, egal.
Tjetke, bevor wir mit dem Stream richtig anfangen.
Falls ihr irgendwelche Stellenanzeigen habt, die wir uns angucken sollten, dann sagt Bescheid.
Vielleicht gibt's was, wo ihr euch bewerben wollt, wo ihr arbeitet.
Und ja, das hatten wir auch schon öfters.
Leute, die ihre Stellenanzeigen geschickt haben, so nach dem Motto, Max, wie findest du das?
Würdest du dich darauf bewerben?
Weil ich bin immerhin, hier im Stream muss man ja auch mal sagen, ich bin ja quasi so das Klientel, was man ansprechen möchte mit seinen Stellenanzeigen.
Ansonsten gucken wir bei den üblichen Verdächtigkeiten.
Wir gucken mal bei den üblichen Verdächtigen ein bisschen durch, was einen da so anspringt.
Leider habe ich gerade kein LinkedIn Fake Account.
Auf LinkedIn gibt's auch immer lustige Sachen.
Auf LinkedIn eskalieren sie in letzter Zeit ein bisschen.
Mit ihren Posts, ähm, how to fire people und sowas.
Die ganzen CEO, oder sagen wir mal so, die ganzen fünf Mann, ja einfach in Chat rein eliminieren, wie man früher gesagt hat.
Die ganzen Möchtegern-Fünf-Mann-Unternehmen-CEOs, die sich so übelst abfeiern.
Auf LinkedIn und...
Man kann das gar nicht beschreiben.
Das ist teilweise so cringe.
Heute Morgen habe ich einen Post gelesen von einem...
Dell wurde data li...
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Schick mal...
Gibt's da was von Heise oder so?
Schick mal.
Hab ich nicht mitbekommen, ja.
Heute Morgen habe ich einen Post gelesen von einem...
Einem CEO.
Und der hat geschrieben...
Also das war eine englische Stellenanzeige.
Er sucht quasi einen Assistent.
Und, also wohlgemerkt, das war ein Unternehmen, was vor einem Jahr noch vier Mitarbeiter hatte.
Und jetzt gewachsen ist auf zwei bis zehn.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie man sich das vorstellen soll.
Sind die jetzt gewachsen oder geschrumpft?
Ich interpretiere immer noch das Schlechteste rein.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile ist er alleine mit seinem Assistent oder so.
Das ist, das ist so eine typische LinkedIn-Sache.
Unternehmensgröße, vier.
Nächstes Jahr, zwei bis zehn.
Ja was denn jetzt?
Ist das jetzt 50% geschrumpft oder 200% oder 3% gewachsen?
Naja.
Habe ich heute auch wieder so einen LinkedIn-Post gesehen.
Von einem CEO, der sich, der sich super, super abgefeiert hat.
Gemeint, er sucht, er sucht einen Assistent.
Und...
Er hat gesagt, es ist eine Position, wo man viel lernen kann.
Und bitte fragt erst gar nicht nach dem Gehalt.
Das macht sich nicht gut.
Und das ist eine...
Das war auf Englisch geschrieben.
Das ist eine super Learning Opportunity, einem CEO on fire aus der first row über die Schulter zu schauen.
Das hat der Typ wirklich über sich geschrieben.
Das ist so lost, was da auf LinkedIn geschrieben wird.
Man, das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen.
Möchtet ihr nicht auch umsonst arbeiten als Assistent aus der front row für einen CEO von einem zwei bis zehn Mann Unternehmen, was richtig on, der richtig on fire ist?
Boah, ich habe übelst Lust, Leute.
Da nehme ich jetzt hier ohne Gefahr meinen Traumarbeitgeber, ja.
Ja, so liest sich das fast.
Learning Opportunity.
Ihr wisst doch, das ist genauso wie auf YouTube und Twitch und sonst wo.
Leute, die Emotes machen, Intros machen und Thumbnails machen und sowas.
Total oft die Antwort bekommen.
Ja, wir bezahlen dich mit Exposure.
Dass er sich von Exposure allein nichts zu, nichts zu fordern kaufen kann.
Ja.
passen in meinem Kopf nicht zusammen.
Warum brauche ich
Geo-Informations über D-Bus?
Whatever.
Egal.
Der hat ja nicht gesagt, dass er umsonst arbeiten soll.
Der hat nur gesagt, man soll erst gar nicht
asken, für wie viel es gibt.
Weil das so eine
geniale Learning-Opportunity ist.
Leute, ich bin
ein wenig, ich bin minimal
stolz auf mich. Ich habe meine
Social-Sachen letztens
besser im Griff gehabt als sonst.
Und zwar, ihr wisst ja, ich bin
oftmals über jeden Scheiß gerne getriggert.
Was mir besonders auf den Sack geht,
wenn irgendwie einer
mir erzählen will, wie ich was
machen soll und so. Obwohl
das ein Thema ist, womit ich mich auskenne.
Oder mir erzählt,
das stimmt nicht, obwohl das aus meiner Sicht
genau richtig umgesetzt ist. Also, ihr kennt mich,
ich bin ja immer ganz gerne ein bisschen getriggert von allem möglichen.
Und letztens auf einem
unserer Dailies
meinte jemand aus dem Team,
zu mir so, Max,
du erzählst immer so wenig
im Daily. Und ich sagte, ja gut, gibt da auch
nichts wirklich Interessantes, ne?
Gut, du hast mich jetzt
exposed, dass ich nichts mache, aber
was soll ich groß erzählen?
Ich mache ja absichtlich, ich erzähle ja absichtlich nicht so viel.
So, und er meinte, ja,
er hat so irgendwie die Bedenken, ich würde was machen
und das dann absichtlich
nicht sagen, damit es keiner mitbekommt.
Da habe ich mir so erstmal, da war ich erstens,
da war ich erstens ganz kurz davor, mich aufzuregen,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, Leute,
was haben die Leute immer für
Fantasien, man? Ich mache das
absichtlich, damit wir unsere
15 Minuten einhalten. Wir haben
15 Minuten Daily, in dem zu 95%
komplett überflüssiges Zeug
gelabert wird. Da mache
ich halt einfach nicht mit.
So, zumal
wir uns auf unserem letzten
Team, frag mich nicht,
Workshop, explizit darauf geeinigt
haben, dass es vollkommen okay sein
muss, damit wir das so in der Art und Weise
machen können, wenn man sagt, ich hab nix.
Und ich praktiziere das auch. Ich sage
wirklich in unserem Daily nur was,
wenn es was Relevantes ist und was auch alle
interessieren können. Mich interessiert auch
nicht, was die Leute für Tickets bearbeitet haben
oder was für,
ja, keine Ahnung, irgendwie
bei irgendwelchen Services, wovor ich keine Ahnung
von habe, irgendwas gefixt wurde.
Wenn das nicht das Team betrifft, hat das auf der
Teamrunde erst einmal pauschal
nix zu suchen.
So, und so mache ich
das auch. Zumindest, ich habe mich
zusammengerissen und war nicht getriggert,
ich kenne denjenigen schon,
der ist, der meint das nicht so,
ja, genauso wie ich mich da
ein bisschen, der meint das nicht so, der meint das
eigentlich gar nicht böse. Da habe ich mir gedacht,
okay, den rufst du jetzt
einfach danach nochmal an. Und
da haben wir da kurz drüber geredet
und da hat er gemeint, ja wahr, das
meint er auch gar nicht so, wie es sich angehört
hat. Und
ihn würde einfach ein bisschen
mehr interessieren, was im Cloud-Umfeld
so abläuft. Da habe ich gesagt,
okay, das kann ich nachvollziehen,
gerade weil man da nicht so viel damit zu tun hat.
Ja, wenn es da irgendwas gibt, ich überlege
mir mal, vielleicht gibt es da da irgendwas,
was, ja, zumindest
ein paar interessieren können. Mal gucken,
ich achte mal drauf, ob es da tatsächlich
vielleicht irgendwas gibt. Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay,
ich glaube, so ist das, wie
das sozial normale Menschen
handhaben.
Also nicht so, wie ich das normalerweise mache.
Ich glaube,
so, wie ich das diesmal
gemacht habe, ist
das, wie das normale Leute,
machen. Ich bin mir
aber nicht sicher, weil
ich bin ja nicht so wirklich
normal, was soziale Sachen angeht.
Ich habe letztens einen Artikel
gelesen, da habe ich echt erstaunlich
viel von mir drüber wiedererkannt.
Das war ein Artikel,
der hat geschrieben,
Artikel ist zu viel gesagt, das war
ein Reddit-Post. Und er meinte,
er hat
nach 20 Jahren
oder so, irgendwie in einem Dreh,
hat er gemerkt,
dass er eigentlich nicht
sich, in Anführungszeichen,
normal verhält,
sondern sich abguckt, wie andere
Leute sich normal verhalten,
um das dann auch zu machen, ohne wirklich
jetzt genau zu verstehen,
warum die Leute das in der Situation
sich so und so verhalten. Und da habe ich
mir ein paar Mal, das fand ich
echt gut geschrieben,
kurz nebenbei gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Da habe ich mich echt wiedererkannt,
weil gerade,
weil gerade in so vielen
Social-Situationen,
wo ich damit überhaupt nichts anfangen kann,
mache ich das auch
total oft.
Mir zu überlegen, okay,
wie würde sich denn jemand anderes
jetzt in dieser Situation verhalten,
beziehungsweise, was habe ich schon mal gesehen?
Keine Ahnung, kann durchaus sein.
Also ganz ehrlich,
man kann ja
nicht sagen,
0% und 100%, so in dem Sinn,
aber
ich glaube,
also bei allen meinen Sachen bin ich auf jeden Fall
eher auf der Autismus-Seite
als auf der Auf-gar-kein-Fall-Seite.
Gerade was meine
sozialen Sachen angeht, ey.
Aber ich kann mich wenigstens zum größten Teil
zusammenreißen. Und eine Sache,
eine Sache hat bei mir
echt enorm geholfen,
und das ist, sich nicht mehr zu irgendeinem
Scheiß zwingen, wozu man keinen Bock hat,
sondern sich zu trauen,
weil das ist überhaupt nichts Schlimmes,
zu sagen, wenn man keinen Bock hat.
Ja? Gerade wenn,
wenn ich auf irgendwelche Sachen mit,
ey, wir gehen heute Abend noch was trinken, oder so,
wenn ich dann sage, ey, das ist mir zu spät, ich muss noch ein paar andere Sachen machen,
ähm, viel Spaß,
die nehmen das einem zu 99%
gar nicht übel. Früher habe ich mich
tatsächlich nicht getraut, da bin ich dann
manchmal mit bei solchen Sachen, obwohl ich eigentlich
gar keinen Bock hatte, seitdem ich jetzt einfach
sage, oh ne, oder auch Sommerfest und
sowas, da sage ich immer, klar, ich ne, die wissen das schon
mittlerweile, die sagen, ah gut, der Max kommt eh nicht,
naja, wohl, aber viel Spaß, Leute.
Die nehmen einem das nicht krumm.
Und wenn sie es einem
krumm nehmen, dann ist das ihr Problem.
Ja, Leute, falls ihr noch
Stellenanzeigen habt, die wir uns angucken
sollen,
weil ich LinkedIn so mag, ja,
alles.
Daily Reports Customer Data Preach, aha.
Jahres Kickoff. Ey,
Jahres Kickoff ist bei uns gar nicht so schlecht.
Jahres Kickoff ist bei uns viel besser.
In der letzten Firma, wo ich war,
da war Jahres Kickoff immer eine
Vor-Ort-Veranstaltung,
die haben sie früher öfters im
English Theater abgehalten, das haben die sich,
äh, gemietet, äh, kennt das, kennt das jemand
in Frankfurt? Da haben die sich das Ding
gemietet und haben dann auf der Bühne ihre,
ihre, ja, Motivationsreden
geschwungen und das war so
cringe bei uns früher, wirklich.
Das war, wie soll,
wie, wie kann, ich muss euch das vormachen,
ich muss euch das vormachen, anders kann,
beschreiben reicht nicht. Das war dann
so, und wir haben wieder
eine Umfrage zur Mitarbeiterzufriedenheit
gemacht. Und was
kam raus?
Ein sehr gutes Ergebnis.
Und wir haben wieder
einer weiteren, äh, Kundenumfrage
erster Platz bei den
besten Außendienstleuten gewonnen.
Und
auch für dieses Jahr
sind wir wieder die Besten der Besten
und für die Besten und die Allergeilsten.
Das ging ohne Scheiß.
Das war, das ist nicht übertrieben,
das war alle
15 bis 30 Sekunden
Applaus, unsere
Jahres Kickoffs früher.
Und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher,
dass sie damals sogar
so Anklatscher im Publikum sitzen hatten.
Also, es gab,
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten bei dem letzten
Laden, wo ich war. Entweder,
also wie gesagt, nicht beim aktuellen,
beim letzten, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten
bei dem letzten Laden, wo ich gewesen bin.
Entweder waren das
wirklich gepriefte, so Anklatscher, so nach dem Motto,
hey, so Leute von, keine Ahnung,
Sekretärin oder so, oder Sekretär.
Oder, das waren Leute, die in diesem
System schon, oder in diesem ganzen,
so
gefangen waren,
dass sie es wirklich gefeiert haben.
Wo hat das nochmal gearbeitet?
Das ist nicht public, das sage ich nicht.
Ich habe, ich habe bei einer
größeren Bank in Frankfurt gearbeitet
und jetzt arbeite ich bei einer Versicherung in Frankfurt.
Da gibt es so viele in Frankfurt, das
kommt nicht, kriegt der nicht raus.
Hast du eigentlich flexible Arbeitszeiten?
Ja, habe ich.
Echt? Es gibt Unternehmen, die in der IT arbeiten
oder arbeitest du in der IT?
Weiß man ja nicht, und die das nicht haben?
Wirklich?
Also, ich hatte das schon immer.
Sogar
beim, bei meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb hatte ich das schon.
Ja, echt jetzt?
Also, ich habe ja meine Ausbildung bei einem Internetprovider gemacht,
der nicht in Frankfurt sitzt.
Also, es ist nicht die Telekom, wie das manche schon öfters immer
da vermuten.
Es ist nicht die Telekom.
Und sogar da hatten wir das.
Ja, ist auch, nein, es ist auch nicht Vodafone gewesen.
Eigentlich völlig unnötig.
Ja, ist es auch.
Also, generell vor Ort zu sein, ist unnötig.
Bei manchen Sachen macht es durchaus Sinn, ab und zu mal, aber bei vielen Sachen ist es,
ja leider, na ja, gut, ja, das stimmt schon, es bleibt auch nicht viel übrig.
Wenn man nicht, um mal zurück zum Thema zu kommen des heutigen Streams.
Nein, ich bin seit 27 Minuten erst online.
Wenn du noch was hast, schick rein.
Vielleicht ist ja heute was für euch dabei.
Hat es denn dort eine flache Hierarchie bei uns, meinst du jetzt?
Ah, nee, würde ich nicht sagen.
Oh, das habe ich noch gar nicht.
Das habe ich schon, das habe ich schon.
Ich glaube, das habe ich schon alles aufgemacht.
Oh, come on, Bange, Modcheck, Modcheck.
Wisst ihr, Bots auf YouTube sind noch viel krasser.
Unter jedem scheiß Video auf YouTube hast du mittlerweile AI,
AI generierte Chatnachrichten oder halt Comments, es ist so schlimm, man erkennt es teilweise
gar nicht mehr richtig, weil mittlerweile verschwimmt Dummheit und AI, also viele Comments,
wo ich denke, dass die AI sind, sind wahrscheinlich gar nicht AI, die Leute sind einfach nur dumm
und umgedreht.
Auf Twitter auch, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was das Top-Bot-Comment auf Twitter mittlerweile
ist?
Nach jedem Post.
Meine Nacktfotos im Profil, kennt ihr das auch?
Twitter-Post.
Ja, meine Nacktfotos im Profil, ist immer, immer auf Twitter, man, was im Post, teilweise
kriege ich irgendwelche Antworten auf Tweets von vor drei Jahren, meine Nacktfotos im Profil,
direkt Bann, alles gebannt, Bange, ich klicke, klickst du das an?
Okay.
Das würde ich vielleicht von meinem Browser unter Linux machen.
So, Package-Updates.
Let's go.
Let's stop.
Package-Updates, dann Reboot, dann gucken wir uns Stellenanzeigen an.
Also, wenn ihr was habt, immer her damit.
Falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, könnt ihr es ruhig nochmal posten, aber ich glaube,
ich habe alles, was bisher gepostet wurde, mitbekommen.
Lass mal kurz gucken, was ist denn bei Dell los?
Dell Reports Customer Data Preach.
Ja, zu kurz.
Ja.
Ja, zum Glück habe ich bei Dell nichts, was gepreacht werden könnte.
Dell warned in an E-Mail, to customer that personal was accessed in a data breach, including
names and addresses to companies located in a .
Und was genau ist passiert?
Und wie genau hat, wie genau, also, was genau ist da jetzt passiert, das ist natürlich
auch immer ganz interessant.
Also, okay.
Dell reagiert nicht auf Warnung vor Diebstahl von Kunden an.
Es ist überall der gleiche Scheiß, man.
Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit der Gamescom?
Bei der Gamescom war es auch so, da hat jemand die Gamescom, beziehungsweise nicht die Gamescom,
die Köln-Messe, muss man ja sagen, darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass man Daten abgreifen
kann über das, also, wenn man dort sich einen Account gemacht hat, konnte man Daten abgreifen
von anderen Leuten.
Und das hat er irgendwie Post vom Anwalt bekommen.
Sowas muss.
Und das ist wichtig.
Sowas muss immer einen riesen Shitstorm geben, dass die alle merken, dass es teurer
ist, sich auf sowas einzulassen, wie einfach ihren Scheiß zu fixen.
Ey, sowas regt mich immer schon auf, wenn ich es einfach nur sehe.
Ja, gut, zum Glück, zum Glück habe ich bei Dell nichts registered und nichts gekauft.
Ja, ist aber kacke.
So, also, let's go.
Mit was fangen wir denn an?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Was haben wir denn hier so?
MPG Trier, Systemadministrator, Cloud-Virtualisierung, ZephDesk, Systemadministrator, MVX, Moment,
das hatten wir doch gerade schon, das hatten wir auch schon, das hatten wir auch schon,
Entry-Level-IT, Architect Expert Lab, jetzt wird es aber abgedreht hier, und ein, ich
glaube, der hier wurde als erstes gepostet, deswegen machen wir den hier auch als erstes,
ein Frontend-Developer für React aus Leidenschaft.
Stand, was zum Teufel ist ein Entry-Level-Expert oder ist das ein Expert-Labs?
Egal, wir fangen mit dem an, was zuerst, was zuerst gepostet wird, also Byte5, Byte5 GmbH,
wo sind die?
Frankfurt, okay, bei mir um die Ecke quasi, guckt mal, davon abgesehen, ich würde nicht
unbedingt React-Developer werden wollen, aber man weiß ja nie.
Ich bin da eigentlich ganz happy, wo ich aktuell bin, aber zeigt mal her, ach, guck
mal hier, die sind in der Nähe vom Ostbahnhof, das ist die, das ist die Europäische Zentralbank
hier, das Ding, was ist da unten, der Knopf, ah, Cookie Stelz, okay, also, wir hatten diese
Stellenanzeige gepostet, ich frage aus dem Grund, ist das eine Stellenanzeige von dem
aktuellen Arbeitgeber von dir?
Willst du dich da bewerben?
Oder nur was, was du zufällig gefunden hast?
Okay, zeig mal her, also, sie suchen einen Frontend-Developer für React aus Leidenschaft,
wie immer, männlich, weiß, deutsch, Byte5 GmbH sichert den Erfolg unternehmenskritischer
Projekte für Mittelstaat, okay, blablabla, ich, ich nehme wohlwollend zur Kenntnis, dass
man seine Selbstlobpreisung auf ein Minimum beschränkt hat.
Nicht wie manch andere Stellungnahme.
Nicht wie manch andere Stellenanzeigen, wo die erste Seite Selbstlobpreisung das Ausschreibende
ist.
Deine Aufgaben.
Als Frontend-Entwickler für, ja, äh, nicht Frontend-Entwickler, JavaScript, für React
betreust du von Anfang an verantwortungsvolle Kundenprojekte mit JavaScript unter Verwendung
gängiger Frontend-Frameworks wie React.
Ich frage mich immer, und das liegt jetzt nicht an dieser, an dieser Stellenanzeige,
ich frage mich immer, warum die Stellenanzeigen so geschrieben sind, wie Stellenanzeigen geschrieben
sind.
Warum schreibt man nicht einfach, ja, mit JavaScript und React unter Verwendung gängiger
Frontend-Frameworks wie React, ihr sucht doch explizit einen React-Developer.
Warum, warum sind die Dinge immer so, so, wie könnte man, wie könnte man das nennen, so,
so um die Ecke geschrieben?
Gemeinsam arbeiten wir mit dir an deiner Reputation als Spezialist.
Whatever auch das bedeuten soll.
Haha.
Was kann ich mir da drunter vorstellen?
Gemeinsam arbeiten wir mit dir an deiner Reputation als Spezialistin, Spezialist, Spezialistin,
was soll mir das sagen?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Nun gut, in deinen Entwicklungsprojekten bist du an allen Projektphasen beteiligt, von Start
über Design, Implementierung und Test bis zum Live-Gang, Abschluss, ja, gut.
Developer, Berater, Trainer, bei uns kannst du alles sein.
Ich, ich meine.
Ich möchte eigentlich Frontend-Entwickler sein.
Kannst du alles sein und dich je nach Vorlieben und Projekt immer wieder neu positionieren.
Bei jedem Schritt deiner Entwicklung kannst du auf das Wissen, die Kontakte und die aktive
Unterstützung des Teams bauen.
Okay.
Also ich kenne enorm wenige Entwickler, gute und auch gute Entwickler, die gerne Berater
beziehungsweise Trainer sein wollen.
Aber kann ja sein, dass es den ein oder anderen gibt, der da Bock drauf hat.
Das bringst du mit.
Wir wollen die Besten noch besser machen.
Ja.
Dafür brauchen wir zur Unterstützung ein Frontend-Dev-Junior-Intermediate.
Was denn jetzt?
Alles.
Sie nehmen alles, oder?
Es ist ja, man könnte es einfach weg lassen.
Okay.
Sie brauchen irgendeinen, der davon Ahnung hat.
Mit Programmiererfahrung und der richtigen Einstellung.
Echte Leidenschaft für das Entwickeln und Gestalten.
Mut und Bereitschaft zum Out of the Box-Denken.
Okay.
Das sind auch immer so krasse, das sind so heftig, so Phrasen, die da immer drinstehen.
Das mit Out of Box-Denken ist so ein Spruch, der steht gefühlt in jeder zweiten Stellenanzeige
drinne.
Spaß an richtig, richtig guten Weblösungen.
Hervorragende HTML, CSS, SCSS.
Ist das überhaupt noch ein Ding seit den letzten CSS-Updates?
Nicht so wirklich, oder?
Typescript, JavaScript-Skills.
Bevorzugen.
Die genannten Frameworks.
Ja, React.
Habt ihr bis jetzt gelernt.
So.
Erfahrung mit Prototyping.
Fick mal.
XD.
XD-ing.
Ne, XD ist das Ding von Adobe.
Aber.
Liest sich jetzt irgendwie so.
Fick mal.
XD.
Agile Grundlagen.
Und selbstständige Arbeitsweise.
Sorry.
Agile.
Agile Basics.
Und wer, Leute, und wer keine Agile Basics hat, muss jetzt mal schauen, wie man das
hier machen kann.
Also, wenn ihr euch das hier anschaut, dann wisst ihr, wie man das hier machen kann.
ja die mail habe ich habe ich auf der arbeit bekommen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen da muss ich mich mal ich möchte euch in
diesem agilen wake up beispiel und best practices für das agile arbeiten
vorstellen dabei beginnt der vortrag mit einem kleinen landing und geht dann auf
zwei bis drei beispiel du brauchst eindeutig einen agilen wake up dass du
das machen kannst hier fähigkeiten auf deutsch und englisch zu kommunizieren so
arbeiten wir ich muss sagen das letzte dreiviertel jahr über hat sich mein
englisch enorm verbessert also dass das ich kann reden auf englisch enorm
verbessert einmal weil weil man auf der arbeit öfters mal mit leuten aus spanien
reden musste auf englisch und was aber hauptsächlich bei mir was bringt dass ich
wieder mmo kreisel client mache und dort mit einer gruppe aus franzosen italienern
und
schweden spiele ich dachte jetzt und ein paar deutsch sind auch dabei und da
redet man halt auf englisch natürlich redet man gaming englisch aber wir
labern auch über alle möglichen sachen und das bringt das bringt echt was wenn
man einfach nur ein bisschen schwätzt und weiß dass sie es halt auch nicht
richtig können und man findet versteht sich trotzdem
also da fallen haben die wörter auch schneller wieder ein wenn man halt die
regelmäßig mal ein bisschen redet welches mmo wird gegründet im dark age of camelot auf einem free schad
jeden
ja
game was zwar über 20 jahre alt ist
aber beste version die sie gegeben hat auf ihn
ok also leute wenn du stellanzeigen habt checkt rüber und falls ich über sehe post einfach klein noch mal
ok so arbeiten wir unsere kunde an innovativen blablabla damit sie als benchmark moment was moment moment
wir stellen an unser eigenes arbeitserlebnis und an unsere arbeitsweise selbst hohe ansprüche
damit sie als benchmark für andere tauchen
ich versuche den satz gerade zu verstehen was mir das sagen soll ok das wisst ihr was
da go
gpt
Wo ist das jetzt wo haben wir das versteckt hier ein chat los geht's
ja
was ist in einer stellen an
Anzeige mit diesem satz gemeint
in diesem satz bedeutet dass das unternehmen hohe standards an die qualität seiner arbeit arbeitsweise setzen um als maßstab für andere zu dienen
das unternehmen strebt also nach herausragende ergebnisse zu erzielen die als vorbild für andere die ja das ist eine gute erklärung
Das ergibt sinn das hätte ich gar nicht in worte fassen können verstehe
Hätte man nicht so was schreiben können wir wie wir wollen ein aushängeschild für an irgendetwas ich finde das so so
unverständlich irgendwie was damit gesagt werden soll
außerdem arbeiten wir
agil und präzise
Da kenne ich aber ich kenne auch kein precision framework
Also agile und lean passt schon aber präzise hat man sich da einfach dazu
forschen wir stets noch nach besseren lösungswegen ok nice akzeptieren wir dass man dabei auch mal
scheitert ist man dann immer noch der benchmark arbeiten wir mal zu hause mal im büro oder auch
mal remote okay ich interpretiere das mal home office ist in der theorie möglich aber für den
passenden agilen team spirit bedeutet das weil man ja dafür brennt und leidenschaft hat dass
man freiwillig ins büro kommt und mit den anderen da zusammen abhängt also eigentlich
sehr selten remote und home office weil wir gemeinsam projekterfolge und lassen kolleg in
das hört sich bisschen so an wie wir sind eine familie das ist auch immer so und ich glaube
aber nicht dass ich das negativ meine ich glaube die meinen dass wirklich positiv aber für mich
der schon erfahrung hatte mal mit so einem laden der sagt wir sind alles eine familie und bla
bla
und hin und her ist das immer so ein bisschen grinsch grinsch zu lesen was
uns egal ist wir suchen echte entwickler mit herz
und nicht entscheidend ist für uns daher woher du kommst solange du eine
arbeitserlaubnis hast ja gut ist das ist ja illegal verstehe ob die
berufseinsteiger oder alte hase bist wie du dir dein wissen angeeignet hast dass
es auch dinge gibt die noch nicht kannst du autos das finde ich also wisst ihr
was so eine so einen abschnitt in der art und weise sollten mehr stellen
anzeigen haben das finde ich nice dass das ermutigt ein bisschen auch die
leute die denken wenn man von zehn punkten eigentlich erfüllt sollte man
sich nicht bewerben was ja blödsinn ist dass es auch dinge
geben um wie viel uhr du in den tag startet und produktiv arbeiten zu können
deine benefits bei five irgendwie hat mich der
name kann ein bisschen an blue byte erinnert kennst du das sind die mit
siedler gibt es glaube nicht mehr unsere unternehmenskultur ist von tat kraft
anerkennung und jeder menge spaß geprägt zur besseren vereinbarkeit von beruf und
privatleben bieten wir dir unbegrenzten urlaub das ist und das ist ein
psychologischer trick das ist ein psychologischer trick und das gibt es
auch untersuchungen zu das unbegrenzt urlaub in der regel dazu führt dass sie
leute weniger urlaub nehmen so blödes klingt flexibles home office und
mobiles arbeiten frei enthaltbare arbeitszeiten festanstellung auch
remote möglich okay dann nehme ich das zurück quasi um gesagt damit liest sich
nach halbwegs immer vor ort sein ist es gar nicht sonst würden sie nicht fest
an den remote möglich wisst ihr was die viel bessere formulierung wäre die die
ich dann auch wirklich war positiv hervorheben müsste wenn da stehen würde
unbegrenzt aber mindestens 30 tage oder unbegrenzt mindestens aber 26 tage das
würde ich begrüßen das bedeutet nämlich tatsächlich dann auch dass man was
darauf geben kann das ist nämlich quasi das gesetzliche ja
so nach dem auch darunter geht ja eh nix im endeffekt das heißt man müsste es
nicht schreiben ja aber also das gesetzliche ist was sie sind nicht 26 tage 24 tage
ba8 steppe 8 bei 40 stunden war es glaube ich 24 also das quasi so ok
mindestens das was es überall anders auch gibt aber ohne grenzen
unbegrenzt gibt es tatsächlich untersuchungen gibt es tatsächlich muss
langsam reden kann tatsächlich untersuchungen zu das unbegrenzt urlaub
gleich weniger ohne aufnehmen bedeutet würdest du dich darauf bewerten können
wir uns angucken klein kann man taktik ist ein sonst-annach-istat hat das anwender
fertig okay fest anstelle darüber hinaus bietet ihr bei five ein gehalt das sich
nach deinen fähigkeiten richtung nicht nach deiner fahndungsgeschick okay egal
was jemand auf der anderen seite sagt selbstverständlich richtet sich euer
geld immer oder auch wenn es mal ein bisschen mehr kohle gibt und wann und wie
oft und wie viel immer nach eurem verhandlungsgeschick egal was sie sagen
wir nicht immer dein persönliches budget für weiterbildung und events im
in- und ausland beteiligungsprozesse auf augen was beteiligungsprozesse auf
augenhöhe oder was heißt das so viel wie man wird auch gehört wenn man seinen
senf dazu gibt ich interpretiere das einfach mal so eine tolle lage mit
direkter bahnanbindung und meinblick das
überprüfen
wir gleich mal regelmäßiges team frühstück kostlose gedränge kostenpreis
fitnessstudio war okay moderne bürger und technik außer viel geek charme und
authentik das würde mir tatsächlich gefallen würdigen von top leistung und
grandiosem scheitern okay keine politik keine psychospielchen ich bin skeptisch
wenn sowas schon erwähnt wird ein junges team mit familiären
charakter allein schon das hier klingt
ein bisschen danach und begrenzter urlaub vielleicht meinen sie es auch
gar nicht so aber ganz ehrlich ich glaube ich will das den jetzt nicht in
mund legen was was sie nicht meinen ja aber es ist halt einfach so jeder hat so
unterschiedliche erfahrungen gemacht das ist das ist die art und weise wie ich die
sachen interpretieren und es ist ja letztendlich nach dem wo wir danach
gehen müssen ja also genau so wie unser anschreiben unsere bewerbung der
das erste sind wo uns irgendwie die unternehmensseite kennenlernt ist sowas
hier das erste womit wir in kontakt kommen
da muss man dann halt interpretiert jeder seine eigenen sachen rein eine
offene atmosphäre viel dynamik respekt gegen seine wertschätzung die
möglichkeit also ganz ehrlich ich glaube ich glaube der laden ist nicht übel
ich glaube das ist was er richtung startup die tatsächlich mit voller
begeisterung dabei sind du aber sicherlich nicht irgendwie jetzt die
welt verdienst ja das ist ja was wir mal ausprobieren
moment wo habe ich hier dach dach dach dach dach go chat ist diese stellen
anzeige generiert
schau mal
chat gpt sagt das ist eine eigene stelle anzeige
die frage ist jetzt chat trust wir chat gpt damit oder nicht ich glaube auch
nicht dass die ei generiert ist ich glaube das sind manche abschnitte
eventuell inspiriert aus chat gpt aber die stelle anzeige selbst ist
hand erstellt ist meine einschätzung okay also wer bock hat
been south in frankfurt sucht einen leidenschaftlichen frontend developer
we act wir gucken jetzt mal wo die sind sogar in der stadt der start
straat street ich wohne mal wieder im main okay alles klar
routenplaner hanau mal ein format mit dem ja gut und die ganz normale die
Die ganz normale...
Ach, das ist neben dem Hauptbahnhof.
Ist das.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, wo das ist.
Das ist hier unten am Main.
Am Karpfenweg, ja.
Weiß ich, wo das ist.
Das ist gar nicht so weit weg von da, wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Okay, die haben wirklich eine sehr gute Anbindung, ja.
Okay, alles klar. Nice.
Chat, ich poste es euch nochmal in den Chat, dass ihr es nicht suchen müsst.
Wenn das was für euch ist und ihr Bock drauf habt...
So sieht es aus.
Falls du es nicht vorhin schon gesehen hast, was denn?
Äh...
Das habe ich doch schon aufgemacht hier.
Die da, gell?
Nee.
Äh, wo ist es denn? Ich sehe es nicht.
Hast du schon gepostet?
Versiox?
Achso, du hast das gepostet.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich es. Okay.
Ja.
Nice.
Also, meinen Senf habe ich jetzt ja dazugegeben.
Ich habe schon schlechtere Stellenanzeigen gesehen.
Exzellente Hintergrundmusik.
Ah, das sind eigentlich Updates.
Ah, fuck, ich habe vergessen, mein Sudo-Passwort einzugeben rechtzeitig.
Okay, müssen wir nochmal kurz Package-Updates machen.
Immer her damit, Leute, wenn ihr noch Stellenanzeigen habt.
Und auch falls ich übersehen habe, postet es einfach nochmal.
Was? Adobe XD ist dead?
Okay.
W-w-w-was? Was?
W-w-h?
Cannot stat source wallpaper JPEG.
Sadge.
Warum kann er das nicht?
Warum kann er das nicht statten?
Vielleicht sollte ich mal ein Clean-Bild machen.
Vielleicht geht das besser.
Wie siehst du den Markt aktuell für Junior-Fronten-Entwickler Angular?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Entwickler.
Da bin ich zu wenig informiert drüber.
Gerade was Angular angeht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann dir allgemein sagen, dass es aktuell gar nicht mal schlecht steht für Quereinsteiger.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so gut wie vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr gab es gefühlt ja an jeder Ecke offene Stellen, die diese Probleme hatten zu besetzen.
Das ist ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Aber es gibt immer noch mehr als genug offene Stellen.
Auf jeden Fall werden mehr Leute gesucht, als es Leute gibt.
Angular ist im Business Enterprise Umfeld sehr beliebt, ja.
Zum...
Was hat der für Probleme?
Das...
Das Our-Package sagt man.
Brauche ich Orchis Theme überhaupt?
Hab ich...
Benutze ich das überhaupt?
Nee, oder?
Das benutze ich überhaupt nicht.
Warum habe ich den Shit noch überhaupt installiert?
Weg damit.
Bam.
Piss dich, Alde.
Okay, und jetzt...
Reboot.
Next.
Wen haben wir jetzt hier?
Ich muss mal...
Leute, das ist mir zu...
Zu blendend alles.
Mein neues Fire-Ship-Video.
Also, das ist doch schon viel, viel angenehmer.
Rhyme.
IT-System-Administrator.
Das klingt richtig schön klassisch mal wieder.
Ich sage euch doch immer wieder, Admin-Jobs sterben nicht aus.
Auch wenn sie alle Panik schieben wegen Cloud und sonst was.
Aber letztendlich...
Letztendlich...
Mussten dort auch Server und Infrastruktur administriert werden.
Vielleicht braucht man nicht mehr ganz so viele wie früher.
Aber man braucht immer noch welche.
Und gescheite Leute wachsen da auch nicht auf dem Baum.
Gerade, weil es dort so viele alten Leute gibt, die keinen Bock auf neue Technik haben.
Da habe ich es einfach gescheit, Leute zu finden.
Okay, IT-System-Administrator.
Oh, sorry.
IT-System-Administrator.
Bei Rhyme.
Warum ist das eigentlich auf Englisch?
Okay.
Als eine zentrale Figur in unserem...
In ihrem IT-Department.
Wir machen jetzt...
Wir lassen uns...
Deep L.
Eats.
Als zentrale Figur in unserer IT-Abteilung stellen uns die Verfügbarkeit, Integrität und Vertraulichkeit unserer wichtigsten Systeme sicher.
Insofern, dass reibungslose Funktion...
Insofern, dass reibungslose Funktionieren...
Klingt ein bisschen holperig.
Übersetzt.
Von Server-Netzwerken und Datenleitungen verantwortlich.
Und gestalten unsere IT-Information...
Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Das brauchen wir nicht übersetzen.
Also.
Die Besten der Besten.
Your Tasks.
Virtual Environments.
Man kümmert sich um VMs.
Und zwar optimale Performance und Scalability.
Hoffen wir mal...
Ach, guck mal.
Man kann das Ganze ja auch auf Deutsch stellen.
Easy.
What?
Das ist das ganze Gelaber, nicht drumherum.
Moment.
Da steht jetzt wieder was ganz...
Okay, Leute.
Jetzt müssen wir uns mal beide Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Und gucken, ob da überhaupt das gleiche drin steht.
Also.
Man kümmert sich um VMs.
Virtualisierungsumgebung.
Und zwar...
Da wird nicht vertikal und horizontal.
Da wird sicherlich auch schon diagonal skaliert.
Hyper V.
Da wird es bei mir schon aufhören an der Stelle.
Da ist schon vorbei.
Moment, Moment.
Wo habe ich das denn?
Moment.
Das brauche ich so selten.
Ich habe dazu aber das passende Emote.
Auch wenn man das heutzutage nicht mehr sagt.
Aber vor ein paar Jahren war das voll angesagt.
Ja.
Bruder muss los.
Wenn ich Hyper V sehe.
Active Direct.
Das wird ja immer schlimmer.
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall...
Definitiv nichts, worauf ich Bock hätte.
Aber da geht es ja auch nicht unbedingt krumm.
Active Directory.
Und man managt automatische Prozesse für Windows 10, 11 Clients und Windows Server Environments.
Ach du scheiße.
Teufel.
Weiche, Alter.
Vm Backup, das geht ja noch.
Das ist ja für mich so ziemlich die schlimmste Arbeitsumgebung, die ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Active Directory, Windows Clients, Windows Server und Hyper V Virtualisierung.
Exchange.
Microsoft 365.
Ahhhh.
New Technologies.
You will also be actively involved in planning...
Okay, blablabla.
Boah, da hätte ich ja keinen Bock drauf.
Also, ich sage nicht, dass es schlecht ist.
Ich sage nur, für mich wäre es gar nichts.
Team Spirit.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns mal die deutsche Stellenanzeige dazu an.
Haben wir hier unten...
Ja, das ist tatsächlich die gleiche.
Der mag normal sein.
Ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Das sagt mir nichts.
Ich sage nicht darüber, ob der Laden was taugt oder nicht.
Das wäre bloß absolut gar nichts.
Das wäre eine Horrorvorstellung für mich, wenn ich mich tagtäglich um Windows Server,
Windows Clients und Hyper V...
Und Office 300.
Alter, ich bin der größte Office-Hasser überhaupt.
Exchange, man, wenn ich daran denke.
Die Stellenanzeige hier sieht schon ziemlich viel anders aus, wie das, was die auf Englisch suchen, oder?
Hier steht einfach...
Hier ist es einfach nur ziemlich generic.
Sie gewährleisten den IT-Betrieb, Sicherstellung der Verfügbarkeit, Integrität, Vertraulichkeit der Server-Systeme, Datenleitung sowie...
Sie sind Administrator für Netzwerksysteme sowie der physischen Leitung.
Du bist was?
Sie sind der Administrator für Netzwerksysteme sowie der physischen Leitung?
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung, was sie mir damit sagen wollen.
Kabel im Fahrstuhl gerissen.
Auf geht's.
Let's go.
Runde klettern.
Der Second-Level-Support bei auftretenden IT-Störungen für die Anwender liegt in Ihrer Hand.
End-User-Support.
Jawoll.
Sie ergreifen Maßnahmen zur Schaltung, Wartung und Entstörung.
Sie ergreifen Maßnahmen zur Schaltung?
Chat, wie konkret ergreift man Maßnahmen zur Schaltung?
Habt ihr auch schon mal Maßnahmen zur Schaltung ergriffen?
Die Erstellung und Pflege von Dokumentationen fällt in Ihren Verantwortungsbereich.
Siehst du, wenn ich...
Ach so, auf Knopf, an und aus, Reboot meint ihr.
Ach ja, okay, das kann natürlich sein.
Siehst du, Chat, wenn ich das machen würde, würde dieser Punkt schon mal wegfallen.
Ja, wir wissen ja, das dokumentiert sich dann alles selbst.
Und die Sache ist halt, auch wenn es funktioniert, braucht man es nicht dokumentieren.
Weil wenn es nicht kaputt geht, braucht man keine Dokumentation, weil es ja nie jemand fixen muss.
Ganz logisch.
Ihr Profil, ein abgeschlossenes Fahnenformat...
Ein Tag bei Rhyme.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich ready dafür bin.
Zehn Minuten? Nee.
Nee.
Zehn Minuten gucke ich mir jetzt halt an.
Roboter.
Okay.
Arbeitsatmosphäre und der Vertuner sind die...
Leute, seriously.
Ich weiß überhaupt nichts.
Sagt null darüber aus, ob die gut oder schlecht sind.
Mich persönlich spricht es nicht an.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist.
Also mich spricht weder die englische Variante als auch die deutsche Variante gar nicht an.
Was haben wir dann als nächstes?
Chat, wie gesagt, wenn ihr was habt oder ich es gerade übersehen habe, schreibt es in den Chat.
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
Lohnt sich.
Für unsere Schule suchen wir zum 1.10.
einen technischen Assistenten.
Ist das was in der Schweiz?
Der A. Huber.
Technisch, das klingt so nach Schweiz irgendwie.
Na gut, Trier ist in Deutschland.
Das stimmt schon.
Das kann eigentlich nicht in der Schweiz sein.
Dann weiß ich gar nicht, was die eigentlich genau suchen.
Ihre Aufgaben.
Unterstützung der Schulleiter...
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, was die da suchen.
Für unsere Unterstützung der Schulleiter...
Okay.
Bei der Betreuung des Verwaltungs...
Das klingt nach was extrem schlecht bezahltem.
Ich weiß nicht, woran ich so...
Aber mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, das ist unterirdisch schlecht bezahlt.
Und nervig.
Es gibt den informationstechnischen Ass...
Ich weiß, ich weiß, dass es das gibt, aber danach sucht niemand.
Das wäre legit die erste Stellenanzeige, die ich gesehen habe, die ernsthaft so jemanden sucht.
Unterstützung bei der Betreuung des Schulnetzwerkes, insbesondere Warte und Pflege aller digitalen Entgänge.
Mit unterschiedlichen Betriebssystemen.
Windows, Android, IOS.
Einbindung der schuleigenen Endgeräte.
Zurzeit iPads, Apple TV, Legamaster.
Man kennt es.
Das ist vielleicht wie die Legehähne aus Battlefield.
In die unterschiedlichen MDM...
Warum gibt es überhaupt unterschiedliche MDM-Systeme?
Pflege und Wartung der iPad-Koffer.
Technische Unterstützung der Lehrkräfte im Unterricht bei außerirdischen Betreuungssystemen.
Warte und Pflege aller digitalen Endgeräte.
Unterricht bei außerunterrichtlichen Veranstaltungen.
Mitwirkung bei Planung, Aufbau, Pflege und Wartung von digitalen Infrastrukturunterrichts...
Das ist schon ganz schön...
Die wollen ja alles von dir im Endeffekt.
Betreuung, Warte, Reparatur elektrischer, elektronischer sowie mechanischer Geräte.
Insbesondere der Kopiergerät.
Das ist so eine Art Hausmeister-Netzwerk-Administrator.
In dem Moment...
Hausmeister...
Schrägstrich...
MDM-Administrator-Netzwerk-Typ.
Regelmäßige Durchführung von Druckaufträgen von Kollegen und Ver...
Ist das eine Verarschung, die Stellenanzeige?
Das ist ja geil, das muss ich mir speichern, Mann.
Was ist denn dieses Admin-Sack?
Sack, Win, Biss, Spec Ops...
Äh...
Ob die auch agil arbeiten, Leute?
Die sind so...
Die sind extrem lean und präzise.
Print-Ops machen die, ja.
Beschaffung von Materialen, Bauteilen, Kalkulation von Kosten der elektrischen und elektronischen Infrastruktur...
What the fuck?
Mitwirkung bei der Wartung, Umrüstung, Führung von Schularbeitsplätzen, Unterrichtsräumen...
Du kannst ja nur...
Du darfst doch die Wand streichen, oder was?
Vorbereitung, Durchführung von Schulveranstaltungen, Schulfest, Abitur, Feier- und Unterrichtsbruch...
What the fuck?
Dokumentation der erbrachten Leistungen, abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung im Bereich Elektrotechnik, Elektromechatronik, IT-Bereich, Erfahrung, Kenntnisse und Fähigkeiten bei der Betreuung von Netzwerken, technisch- und handwerkliches Geschick, Selbstständigen und Fahndungsbewerber...
Weiter zur Fort- und Weiterbildung...
Aufgeschlossene und Förderungen mit Jugendlichen und...
No!
God, please, no!
Ich weiß, dass mir dort definitiv alle auf den Sack gehen würden.
Die Schüler, aber ich glaube noch schlimmer die Lehrer.
Identifizierung mit den Zielen und Werten der Schule.
Ich wette mit euch, Ziele und Werte der Schule sind definitiv nicht, dass du ein ordentliches Gehalt bekriegst.
Kommunikations- und Kooperationsbereitschaft insbesondere mit den Hausmeistern und den für die Netzwerk-IT zuständigen Lehrpersonen sowie Externen für Flexibilität, Arbeits...
Arbeits zu Beginn Montag bis Freitag 7 Uhr.
Bis...
Bis fertig ist.
Es handelt sich um eine Landesstelle in Volsam.
Die eingreift in das EndgeldGruppe 6, das Tarifverhältnis...
Oh, das ist glaube ich sehr wenig.
Endgeldgruppe 6 im unbefristeten Beschäftigungsbereich.
Der Erholungsurlaub ist in der Regel in den Schulferien zu nehmen, Bewerbung mit Lebenslaufpflicht bis zum Postalisch...
Selbstverständlich geht das Ganze nicht per...
Oder aber okay, per E-Mail
Okay, wir müssen mal kurz gucken
Was es gibt
Entgeltgruppe 6
Okay, sagen wir mal, du steigst
Irgendwie jemand oder so
Moment, also für den
Für den Stress
Und den Hickhack
Den oder in dem
Ne, wirklich nett
Wirklich nett
Das macht doch niemand
Das ist so eine typische Stelle
Weshalb immer geschrien wird
Fachkräftemangel
Dieses Ding ist wahrscheinlich seit 2, 3 Jahren
Beim Arbeitsamt offen
Niemand bewirbt sich drauf
Und alle fragen sich
Wie kommt es denn nur, dass das keiner machen will
Das ist doch eher so eine Studentenstelle
Naja, ich weiß nicht
Ob das Studentenzeit hat
Montags bis Freitag von 7 Uhr
Let's go
In den Ferien vielleicht
Das sieht nicht so aus
Das ist eine Vollzeitstelle
Wollen da keinen Student haben
Also ganz ehrlich
Das klingt nach einer Stelle
Die so unglaublich abfuckt
Wenn du sie machen musst
Dass du das eigentlich
Noch Schmerzensgeld oben drauf bezahlen müsstest
Nicht nur die nervigen
Schüler
Das geht wahrscheinlich noch
Du hast auch die nervigen Lehrer
Und dass du dich ja wirklich um jeden Scheiß kümmern musstest
Wenn man sich
Du musst sogar
Das steht zwar nicht explizit da
Aber
Hier
Du musst
Wo steht es denn hier noch
Hier
Du musst im Zweifelsfall auch die Wand streichen
Es steht ja auch nicht immer außer
Dass die Android und iOS
Mal ganz davon abgesehen
Das Spektrum
Was hier abgedeckt wird
Ist enorm
Ja
Du sollst dich um irgendwelche MDM Sachen kümmern
Windows, Android
Vor allem Windows
What the fuck
Also, ja gut
Du sollst dich um Kleingeld
Kümmern
Um Mobile Sachen
MDM
iPad Koffer
Du sollst dich um Netzwerk kümmern
Um alle elektronischen Geräte
Druck
Das ist ein enorm
Das ist ein riesengroßes Spektrum
Mit einem
Also wirklich enorm hohem
Nerv
Wie nennt man das
Genervtheitspotential
Und dann
Kriegst du noch einmal was für
Was iPad Koffer sind
Keine Ahnung
Und dann
Mal gucken was Google dazu sagt
Das sind iPad Koffer
Also das ist echt
Also die Stellenanzeige ist echt der Witz
Das macht niemals irgendjemand freiwillig
Und wenn
Dann macht er das mit einer Motivation
Das zu denen die Stelle auch gar nicht hätte es besetzen müssen
Also das ist ein Abfuckfaktor
Also das ist ja wirklich
Das ist eine
Das ist wirklich eines der abschreckendsten Stellenanzeigen
die ich hier seit langer Zeit gesehen habe.
Wie hieß dieses Ding?
MPG?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es gepostet hat.
Sonst hätte ich nämlich mal
geguckt, ob derjenige
sich da vielleicht drauf bewerben
wollte.
Man weiß es nicht, wer es gepostet hat.
Drauf bewerben wollte oder
ob er dort arbeitet oder es einfach gefunden hat.
Falls derjenige sich outen möchte,
der die gepostet hat.
Warum hast du die gepostet, die Stellenanzeige?
Solltest du dafür verantwortlich sein,
Leute zu finden, dann
hoffe ich
oder falls du
da jetzt mitgewirkt hast
an der Stellenanzeige, hoffe ich,
ich habe dich jetzt nicht zu sehr geflamed.
Aber ich glaube, man muss das dann tatsächlich
auch mal so deutlich sagen.
Klar, mach mal, mach ruhig.
Warum nicht?
Ich kann meinen Senf zu fast allem dazugeben.
Wie viel Mehrwert das dann wiederum
bringt, sei mal dahingestellt.
Ach Leute, ich bin übrigens ab 1.8.
höchstwahrscheinlich, also wenn ich das
mache, ich bin mir aber sehr
sicher, weil ich habe also die ganzen
Einzelheiten nur, ich bin da wahrscheinlich
ab 1.8. privat krankenversichert.
1.6.
Ne, 1.8.
Schwachsinn. 1.8.
Nicht 1.6.
1.8.
Ich habe mich jetzt endlich dazu
durchgerungen.
Und der Witz ist, ich bezahle sogar ein bisschen weniger
jetzt noch.
Falls du einen kleinen Lacher
zwischendurch liest, nur die Profile-Section durch.
Agile Project Manager.
Nice.
Moment, haben die das rausgenommen?
Ist das eine Debate-Anzeige?
Mit durchgerungen
meine ich nicht, dass ich je gedacht hätte,
dass es nichts bringt, sondern dass ich bisher
immer zu faul war, mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Das ist eines der Gründe,
warum ich mich letztendlich dazu
entschieden habe, das jetzt zu machen.
Ich bezahle dann irgendwie
800,
120 Euro oder sowas.
Und das ist weniger, als ich gesetzlich
bezahle.
Plus Rückstellungs-Sachen und Dinger
fürs Alter. Also, die sind da schon
drin.
Also, wenn man viel verdient, ist
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung echt absolut
pipiger. Leider.
Ich hätte ja gar keinen...
Ich würde ja prinzipiell gerne gesetzlich
bleiben, aber die
Versorgung ist für den Arsch mittlerweile.
Macht man einen Termin beim Hautarzt?
Ja, dann sehen wir sie in vier Monaten.
Bis dahin ist es entweder weg
oder mir ist, keine Ahnung, das Ohr abgefault oder so.
Doch, doch, man bezahlt
im Alter schon mehr, aber deswegen
ist es mittlerweile auch gesetzlich
Anforderung
oder erforderlich, dass man
ein bisschen mehr bezahlt, um Rücklagen
fürs Alter zu bilden.
Weil damit ein paar Richter auf die Schnauze gefallen sind.
Aber das will man
im Alter nicht, weil im Alter braucht es ja dann
meistens die meiste Leistung davon.
Hast du auch eine Berufsunfähigkeit?
Ja, habe ich.
Aber keine
selbst abgeschlossene, sondern
eine, also
über meinen Arbeitgeber.
Lufthansa Groups.
Okay,
ein Agile Project Manager.
Ach ja, und von
diesen 820 Euro,
die ich bezahlen muss, für die Krankenversicherung,
bezahlt
ich glaube 360 Euro oder so
der Arbeitgeber. Also das, was der...
Also das, was der Arbeitgeber jetzt schon bezahlt,
bezahlt er ja auch.
Also bezahle ich irgendwie so knapp
450 Euro oder so was.
Was immer noch weniger ist.
Schaut's bei deiner Berufs...
Was willst du wissen?
So viele Details weiß ich da aus dem Kopf nicht.
Okay, also,
ein Agile Project Manager.
Ich hoffe, der skaliert diagonal.
Alles andere wäre ja gar nichts.
Schon rausgefunden,
wie groß ein Windrad ist.
Ja, die Leute auf Twitter,
sind tatsächlich deutlich mehr High IQ,
als ich gedacht habe.
Deswegen hab ich ja auf Twitter gepostet.
Natürlich hätte ich selbst danach googeln können.
Aber auf Twitter hat mir jemand geantwortet,
der genau wusste, was das für ein Typ Windrad ist
und die Größe dazu.
Googeln danach hätte ich selbst können,
aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was das eigentlich genau ist.
Ich hab aus dem Kopf keine Ahnung.
Müsste ich auf die Abrechnung gucken.
Okay, NetCup,
ein Agile Project Manager.
Ja, du bleibst du.
Denn so wollen wir dich.
Wir können, wir wollen und wir dürfen auch.
Denn wir sind ein Team aus hochmotivierten und qualifizierten Mitarbeitern,
denen es genauso am Herzen liegt, Kunden zu begeistern,
wie an technischen Lösungen zu bauen.
Das macht uns einzigartig.
Wenn du dich und unsere Produkte weiterentwickeln kannst.
Ich glaube, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich so pauschal gesagt,
NetCup ist gar kein so schlechter Laden.
Sie suchen einen Agile Project Manager,
ab sofort, Vollzeit, Karlsruhe, Wien, Klagenfurt oder Remote.
Du bist das fehlende Bindeglied zwischen Management und den agil arbeitenden Fachabteilungen.
Als Agile Project Manager,
Project Manager sind wir hier,
ja, nicht.
Ähm, bist du dabei eine wichtige Stütze für diese Teams
und übernimmst mit deinem Agilen Mindset eine,
ob die auch Agile Wake-Up Calls machen und eine Vorbildfunktion für die Kollegin,
eine Vorbildfunktion für die Kollegin,
und das Management.
Aha, das ist super agil.
Bei uns koordinierst und leitest du eingefahren,
folgt die Umsetzung.
Als Agile Coach, ich denke ich bin Projekt Manager,
bereust, ja, das würde ich auch bereuen,
Agile Project Manager zu sein.
Als Agile Coach betreust und unterstützt du die agilen Prozesse deiner Kollegen
und legst dabei die Arbeit, die du in deinem Projekt erledigen kannst.
Das ist super agil.
Bei den Fokus auf neue Technologien als cross-punktionales Teammitglied
bist du in allen Fachabteilungen gern gesehen ein wichtiges Mitglied.
Ah, ja.
Wanted.
Also, was wollen sie denn in der agilen Softwareentwicklung?
Scrum.
Begriffe wie Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Python und Golang sind keine Fremdwörter für dich.
Okay.
Ja, sehr 0815.
Auf sowas hätte ich halt überhaupt keinen Bock.
Weiß nicht, für wen das von euch was ist.
Oder wäre gewesen.
Wesen, weil die Stellenanzeige gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Das ist jetzt weder sonderlich gut, noch sonderlich schlecht.
Das ist die Frage.
Ob man da auch erstmal mit einem Agile Landing abgeholt wird.
Ja.
Nachdem man wake-upped wurde.
Okay, next.
Machen wir den hier.
Systemadministrator bei Strato.
SAP-Entwickler.
Okay.
ABAP.
Let's go.
Ich mach das mal kurz hier auf.
Kann man gleich viel besser sich angucken.
Also, machen wir den hier.
Bei Strato.
Systemadministrator Cloud-Virtualisierung.
Voll- oder Teilzeit.
In Berlin, Deutschland.
Ich finde das immer so geil, wie die Amis Deutsche Bank aussprechen.
Ich kann das gar nicht nachmachen.
Deutsche Bank.
Wurde Teil...
Okay, also.
Werde Teil unseres Teams aus Expertinnen und bringe deine eigene Expertise und...
Okay, bla bla bla.
Wir suchen Personen, die für die Administration und...
Brennen.
Alter, bitte mehr sinnlos floskeln, bitteschön.
Wir suchen Personen, die für die Administration und Weiterentwicklung unserer vor allem aber sehenden Clouds genauso brennen.
Und für die, der Blick über den Tellerrand nicht nur eine hohle Floskel ist.
Aber das mit dem Brennen ist schon mal wieder so eine hohle Floskel, ey.
Könnten die nicht schreiben, dass es begeistert dich oder sowas?
Ich find das so ausgelutscht mittlerweile.
Dieses Brennen dafür, ja.
So lange die Server nicht brennen.
Nicht nur OVH brennen die Server.
Bei Google in Paris ist doch auch letztens ein Rechenzentrum abgefackelt.
Die hatten aber richtig die Arschkarte.
Bei Google, die hatten gleichzeitig Überschwemmung, Stromschäden, also Stromschlagschäden und Brände.
Das musste er erstmal schaffen.
Wir betreiben eine Public Cloud Plattform, basierend auf VMware, vSphere, vCloud, Director und NSX.
Chat, wer kann mir erklären, was vDirector und NSX ist?
Hat das auch was mit VMware zu tun oder ist das irgendein eigenes Spezialding von Strato?
Kennt man das?
Ja, ich kenne auch nicht alles.
VMware Staff für Rechenzentrum, ok.
Sowie eine größere Anzahl Private Clouds für unsere Kunden auf Basis von VMware vSphere.
NSX ist Netzwerkvirtualisierung.
Aha, verstehe.
Was wir für dich tun?
Ein hybrides Arbeitszeitenmodell.
Das ist jetzt alles?
Nachhaltiger Arbeitsort in Friedrichshain, unbefristeter Arbeitsvertrag, Weiterbildung, so wie du sie brauchst, ok, alles.
Finanzielle Unterstützung beim Wohnortwechsel in Höhe von 1.000.000 Euro.
Davon kannst du aber nicht deinen Wohnort wechseln.
30 Tage Urlaub, kostenloses Deutschlandticket, Rabatt auf Gyms, Mitarbeiterrabatt.
Ganz ehrlich?
Wenn das Gehalt taugt, scheiß auf kostenloses Deutschlandticket.
Da kann ich auch bezahlen.
Mitarbeiterrabatt auf Strato-Produkte und 1&1-Produkte.
Fahrrad leasen mit...
Das haben enorm viele Arbeitgeber mittlerweile.
Angebot zur Gesundheitsförderung, Gruppenunfallversicherung, Grippeimpfung, Augenkontrollansuche und so weiter.
Das ist gar nicht mal übel.
Mitgliedschaft bei...
Wen juckt's?
Dein Aufgabenbereich.
Entwicklung und Administration hochverfügbarer Systemlandschaften und Virtualisierungsplattformen verschiedener Größe.
Pflege der Server und Speicher, NetApp, ja, was sonst?
Backup-Systeme, WM sowie der Infrastrukturkomponenten, Betreuung der Geschäftsgründe, aktive Mitwirkung an der Automatisierung des Monitors der Systemlandschaften.
Okay, klingt ziemlich Standard nach Systemadministrator.
Was du mitbringen solltest?
Praktische Erfahrungen im Design und der Administration von Vmware-Plattformen.
Ja gut.
Wenn's hier hauptsächlich um Vmware geht, wäre es sinnvoll, sich mit Vmware auszukennen.
Erfahrung mit Backup-Technologien.
Netzwerk-Grundlagen hochverfügbar ins Storage-System.
Bereitschaft zur...
Was?
Bereitschaft zur Bereitschaftsdiensten.
Gesondert vergütet, ja, da müsste man ordentlich was raushauen.
Automatisierung mit Enable Terraform Shit.
Und Shell-Skripting.
Ja, das klingt ja nach einer guten Standardkombination.
Sichere Deutschkenntnis und Englischkenntnis.
Also fühlst du dich im Team am wohlsten.
Und kannst mir nicht mehr sagen, ja, Pluspunkt.
Pluspunkt.
Ja.
Ist eine...
Keine schlechte.
Würde ich sagen, 0815-Stellenanzeige.
Wenn man scharf drauf ist,
ja, was mit Virtualisierung und Vmware zu machen.
Und aus der Nähe kommt, warum nicht?
Ist jetzt nichts, was einen beim Lesen irgendwie in Verzückung versetzt.
Zumindest mich nicht.
Ist aber auch nicht mein Spezialgebiet, muss man ja auch sagen.
Denke ich durchaus, okay.
Was es an Kohle gibt, kann man sich überhaupt nicht ableiten, keine Ahnung.
Müssen wir jetzt mal nachgucken, ob es da irgendwie was gibt, wenn man hier nachsucht.
Mal bei Strato in Berlin, was da so die Range ist.
Gehe davon aus, erstens ist es keine Senior-Position.
Und zweitens, ja, so Hosting-Sachen, Hosting-Anbieter sind jetzt nicht unbedingt dafür bekannt.
Das sind jetzt so die allerkrassesten Gehälter.
Und das ist jetzt nicht so einfach, um die anzuzahlen.
Ich denke mal, es wird schon ganz okay sein.
Ja, sehr 0 nach 15 die Stellenanzeigen. Ist jetzt nicht schlecht.
Chat, was sagt ihr dazu?
Würdet ihr euch bewerben, wenn ihr in Berlin wohnen würdet?
Ja oder nee?
Könnt ihr mal danach immer so ein bisschen den Chat mit einbeziehen.
Den Job nicht Remote anzubieten, das ist eine gute Frage.
Na gut, die wollen wahrscheinlich die Leute da vor Ort im Rechenzentrum auch haben.
Was ich durchaus verstehen kann, weil das ist ein Hoster.
Die haben sehr viel eigene Infrastruktur.
Und ein bisschen liest sich das schon so, als muss er da auch mal ins Rechenzentrum ab und zu.
Cloud findest du eher uninteressant.
Ja, jeder was, was er macht.
Wie gesagt, wir sind uns ja alle einig, dass nächstes Jahr das Jahr von Serverlessness wird.
Da kannst du in Berlin noch nicht mal dein Foto davon bezahlen.
Doch, kannst du wahrscheinlich, aber bleibt nicht viel übrig.
So.
Ja.
Ich bin jetzt nicht so geschockt.
Als nächstes SAP Entwickler.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was da abgeht.
Bei den ABAP Hackermans.
SAP Entwickler.
Versicherungsbranche.
Aha.
Quasi.
Bisschen, bisschen, bisschen dort, wo ich jetzt.
Ich meine nicht als SAP Entwickler, aber Versicherungsbranche bin ich jetzt auch am Start.
ABAP Hackermans.
Was ist hier los?
Du hast dein IT-Studium von Erfahrung.
Erfahrung SAP-Umfeld auf Entwickler-Ebene.
Zudem bist du kommunikativ und lösungsorientiert.
Dann suchen wir genau dich als IT-Entwickler.
In der SAP-Entwicklung im Rahmen deiner Tätigkeit bla bla.
Ja, ja, bla bla bla bla.
Unser Kunde, ein erfolgreiches Versicherungsunternehmen, sucht zeitnah.
Nicht, dass das mein Arbeitgeber letztendlich ist.
Weil wir haben auch viel SAP-Geschiss.
Ähm.
Auf dich wartet ein spannendes Aufgabenfeld.
Nehmen du deine Kenntnisse ein, bringen wir weiter von dir.
Haben wir dich überzeugt?
Ganz ehrlich, ihr habt nichts geschrieben bis jetzt, was mich überzeugen könnte.
Dann bewirb dich noch heute und gehe den nächsten Schritt in dein Land.
Da steht ja noch nichts dazu da, wirklich.
Das erwarte dich bei uns.
Übernahme der Produktverantwortung für ausgewählte technologische SAP-Komponenten.
Machen wir mal einen SAP-Stream.
Nee, ich habe keine 3 Millionen übrig, damit man da einsteigen kann.
Konzeption und Gestaltung, Umsetzung von Softwareanwendungen, Entwicklung, Anpassung, Dokumentation, neue Technologien sowie individuelle Fiori-Apps.
Wie viele Pluginsachen gibt es bei SAP eigentlich?
Ich meine, ich habe von SAP wenig Ahnung.
Aber so ein paar Buzzwords von Fiori habe ich bis jetzt noch nichts gehört.
Ein Subgoal für SAP-Streams.
Das muss aber ein hohes Subgoal sein.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe letztens Dinge über die SAP-Cloud gehört.
Da muss ich kecken.
Aber es ist ein Geheimnis.
Auch wenn ich nichts unterschrieben habe.
Weiterentwicklung der Fiori-Strategie, alles klar.
Mitarbeiter bei der Migration auf SAP S slash 4 HANA.
Das habe ich schon gehört.
Das kenne ich.
Das ist irgendeine Datenbank.
Irgendetwas, was Millionen kostet, wenn du da eine größere Umgebung hast.
Abstimmung mit Anwendungsberatern.
Ja klar, die müssen den Krempel für 100.000 ja auch an den Mann oder an die Frau bringen.
Ein jährliches Gehalt zwischen...
Okay, schon mal ein großer Pluspunkt, dass ganz klar hingeschrieben wird, was es für Kohle gibt.
Die Range ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, sehr eng.
Und ich glaube für SAP-Experten tatsächlich auch noch eher am unteren Rand, oder?
SAP ist bei mir im Kopf immer...
Ist abfuck, keiner will es machen, aber wird fett bezahlt.
Eine Festanstellung direkt bei unserem Kunden.
Die Möglichkeit innerhalb Deutschlands bis zu vier Tage pro Woche auf Remote.
Sehr gut.
Dass das so drinne steht.
30 Tage Urlaub und flexible Arbeitszeiten.
Betriebliche Altersvorsorge, Jobrat, Fahrrad...
Gut, das haben viele.
Kostenlose Parkplätze, das ist tatsächlich, wenn man da öffnet, das ist echt ein Vorteil.
Individuelle Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten.
Das bringst du mit abgeschlossenen Studien mit IT-Schwerpunkt, Berufserfahrung, SAP-Umfeld, logisch.
Fiori.
ABAP, jawoll, da ist es, endlich.
ABAP.
Verhandlungssichere, also wer das mal sehen will.
ABAP, Hello World.
Man kann nicht einfach mal einen Hello World machen in einem Texteditor.
Das punzt bei SAP nicht.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, ein bisschen ein älteres Beispiel schon.
Informatik verstehen, so so.
Ja.
ABAP, Hello World.
Hohes Maß an Kommunikationsstärke und Selbst...
Also, ich kann dazu nichts im Detail sagen, weil ich von SAP keine Ahnung habe.
Für meinen Geschmack ist es...
Also...
Ich kenne halt nur so andere Sachen, die mit SAP zu tun haben.
Und da ist das gefühlt schon fast ein bisschen wenig.
Schwer zu sagen, kommt auch immer auf die...
Ich tue mir immer schwer zu sagen, ein bisschen wenig.
Weil ich weiß, dass das ein Gehalt ist, was wahrscheinlich sogar noch über dem Durchschnitt von Deutschland liegt.
Aber ich kenne es halt aus dem SAP-Umfeld, dass die sich alle dumm und dämlich verdienen, aber keiner Bock drauf hat.
Ja.
Wenn man Bock auf SAP hat, warum nicht?
38 Stunden.
Die hier unten, die Sachen lesen sich nicht schlecht.
Mehr kann ich da nicht zu sagen.
Weiß nicht, was der Durchschnitt ist.
Gerade aus dem Kopf.
Keine Ahnung.
Was haben wir denn jetzt?
Oh, der grinst uns aber.
Schau mal.
SAS an.
Erstmal die goldene Armbanduhr am Start.
Komm in die Gruppe.
Penetration Testers, all genders.
Ich weiß, wie es gemeint ist, aber...
Das kann man schon falsch verstehen.
Du hast eine Leidenschaft für Pentesting.
Prüfst IT-Systeme und Applikationen mit offensiven Methoden auf Schwachstellen.
Zeigst den Kunden Optimierungspotential auf.
Dann bist du hier richtig.
Du hast den Valomat noch nicht verpasst.
Nee, aber nicht gemacht.
Aha, Raunheim.
Das ist doch...
Wollte ich gerade sagen.
Da bin ich doch letztens durch...
Nee, das ist bei Rüsselsheim.
Da bin ich nicht mit dem Fahrrad durchgefahren.
So weit...
So weit war ich nicht mit dem Fahrrad.
Nein, das ist ja bei Mainz hier.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ganz so weit war ich noch nicht mit dem Fahrrad.
Also das weiteste mit dem Fahrrad von Hanau aus war hier mal eine Runde um Rottgau rum.
So 60 Kilometer, 62 Kilometer.
Irgendwie so war das.
Seligenstadt fahre ich öfters.
Ich will demnächst...
Mal probieren.
Von Hanau nach Seligenstadt.
Hier unten am Main lang.
Nach Seligenstadt zu laufen hin und zurück.
20 Kilometer sind das.
Das sind ungefähr...
Ja, so 10,5 Kilometer hin.
Also so 21 Kilometer hin und zurück.
Relativ langsam.
Mal gucken wie lange ich...
Mal gucken wie lange ich brauche und ob ich es packe.
Also 10 Kilometer am Stück packe ich mittlerweile easy.
Deswegen...
Das längste was ich bisher gelaufen bin waren glaube ich 14.
Und...
Deswegen habe ich die Hoffnung, dass ich das ganz gut packe.
Wenn ich langsam laufe, mal kurze Pause machen in Seligenstadt und zurück renne.
Ich peile irgendwas so, sagen wir mal um...
6,50...
7 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Das ist schon recht gemächlich.
An...
Das sollte gut drin sein.
Vielleicht, wenn ihr wollt, kann ich meine GoPro mitnehmen.
Dann kann ich meine erste, das ist ja quasi schon Halbmarathon Distanz mal aufnehmen.
Und daran...
Okay, das mache ich. Ich habe hier so ein GoPro-Umhänge-Ding.
Hast du da dann auch ein Ziel?
Oder einfach so um zu laufen?
Das Ziel ist es zu packen in einer halbwegs ordentlichen Zeit.
Also erstmal zu packen.
Was ist der Plan, wenn man es nicht schafft?
Ja, Pause machen zwischendurch einfach.
Und dann weiter.
Oder ich fahre heim.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, wenn ich das packe,
ist das echt ein Beleg für
das mit ein bisschen Übung,
das jeder schaffen kann, sowas.
Ich bin fast 40.
Ich sitze den ganzen Tag vorm Computer.
Und regelmäßig
Sport mache ich,
also wirklich mit ein bisschen Plan dahinter,
mache ich seit letztem Jahr im August.
Also wenn ich das packe, kann das jeder
mit ein bisschen Übung packen.
Okay, also was wird hier sonst noch gesucht?
Also Penetration Tester.
Schwerpunkt
deiner Tätigkeit liegt in der Vorbereitung
von Penetration Tester. Speziell ist es dabei auf
Web Applications,
Web Services, API Pentesting.
Gut, ich meine, du kannst natürlich nicht von allem Ahnung haben.
Infrastructure
und Cloud Pentesting, Mobile Pentesting,
iOS, Android, Rich Internet
Application, FAT Client.
Ja, das ist
mit Abstand mein Lieblingsclient.
Pentesting, Reverse
Engineering, Embedded Device und
gerade Embedded Devices würde ich
sagen, ist ein bisschen was,
was irgendwie auch zu Lufthansa
passen würde.
Des Weiteren gehört auch die Planumsetzung von Techniken,
Reviews, Audits, so dein, ja,
das klingt alles sehr passend.
Zudem verfolgst
du aktiv die Sicherheitsentwicklung Technologien
am Markt. Ja, würde ich auch von jedem
Security Mensch erwarten.
Darüber hinaus unterstützt du
Vertriebsaktivitäten, wie zum Beispiel
Präsentation, Angebotsvorbereitung, wie die
du auf dem Internet steckst.
Also es mag sicherlich Leute geben,
die sowas gerne machen,
aber die richtigen Hardcore Hackermans,
die man eventuell hofft,
hierfür zu finden,
das sind nicht unbedingt diejenigen,
die so zwangsläufig auf sowas hier stehen.
Die haben eher keinen Bock auf
Vertriebsaktivitäten, glaube ich.
Ja.
Ich glaube, Lufthansa ist kein schlechter Arbeitgeber
und ich glaube, das ist keine schlechte
Stelle, wenn man die Skills dafür hat.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dazu.
Ganz ehrlich, ich sehe das sogar noch
ein bisschen anders. Die Hardcore Hackermans,
die das Skill haben,
den Skill haben, plus sowas
hier gerne machen, die haben wahrscheinlich
eine eigene Hackermans Firma und
machen super krass viel Kohle.
Was macht man als Pentester bei Lufthansa denn
für den Vertrieb? Da steht ja da,
Präsentation, Angebotsvorbereitung.
Wahrscheinlich nehmen sie dich
mit, wenn sie irgendwas verkaufen
wollen, als Experte
und du musst dann da eine gute Figur machen.
Keine Ahnung.
Benefits.
Beflügelndes Umfeld.
Das ist schön umschrieben.
Abgeschlossen.
Fundierte Erfahrungen im Umgang mit offenen
Werkzeugen. Burp! Das ist ein Proxy.
Warte mal.
Nee.
Burp ist quasi das gleiche
wie mit dem Proxy, nur dass es Burp
ist. Metasploit
Kali. Ah, Hackermann.
Da muss ich bei der Gelegenheit, der immer die Story
erzählen, dass mal bei uns
auf der alten Arbeit Leute von
der Security reingerannt sind, weil
irgendjemand sich auf einem Laptop
übers WLAN von USB Stick
Kali Linux Package Updates gemacht hat.
Die haben nur im Proxy irgendwie
gesehen, Hackermann Tools
werden runtergeladen, was ist hier los?
Attacke!
Letztendlich hat der nur sein Kali Linux
aktualisiert.
Zertifizierung im Bereich offensiver
IT Security
wünschenswert. Zum Beispiel
USB.
Siehste, ich kenn mich in dem Bereich nicht aus.
Was ist USB?
Die Pen 200. Penetration Attesting
Certification mit Kali Linux.
Okay.
Ausgeprägte Beratungskompetenz.
Flexibilität
sowie sehr gute Kommunikation.
Auch auf...
Seid ihr euch sicher? Wollt ihr
nen krassen Pentest Hackermann?
Reverse Engineer Dude?
Oder einen der guten Business?
...
Aber soll ich...
Ich...
...
Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich es so
beobachten soll.
Aber...
...
Es ist selten.
Und viele von denen haben ihren eigenen Laden.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ob die da so fündig werden.
Ich meine, ich halte mittlerweile
mein Weg zu von
ich hasse es zu, ich mache es ganz gerne
erzählt.
Beratschaft zum Projekt bezogen Reisezielen.
Das ist halt auch so ein Ding,
wo nicht jeder Bock drauf hat.
Also, ich habe die Vermutung,
man sieht ja hier keine
Gehaltsspannung.
Also, ich habe die Vermutung, wenn die das hier
wirklich ernst meinen, bezahlen die auch
wirklich gut. Würde ich mal für sie hoffen, sonst werden sie
nämlich niemanden finden.
Dann ist das sicherlich eine Überlegung wert.
Ich glaube, Lufthansa und
in dem Bereich ist es sicherlich interessant.
Es ist bestimmt auch kein schlechter Arbeitgeber.
So sagt mir jetzt mein Bauch gefühlt
und Bauch, ne, habe ich genug
für, wobei, ich habe gar nicht mehr so viel Bauch,
Leute. Was verdient, ich habe
keine Ahnung. Aber 100k
plus würde ich schon tippen.
Wenn die das dann
wirklich auch ernst meinen, was sie hier schreiben.
Weil die wollen ja nicht
irgendjemand, der mal
Ubuntu in der VM installiert hat
oder ein .NET Programm
in einem
Decompiler
aufgemacht hat, sondern jemand, der wirklich Ahnung hat
von dem, was er da treibt.
Ich habe Hunger, Leute, ich muss was essen.
Ich mache euch einen Vorschlag.
Während ich esse,
machen wir den Valomat zusammen.
Weil es ist, glaube ich, nächsten Monat.
Ziemlich genau an einem Monat ist das, ja.
Und danach gucken wir uns die letzten zwei
Stellenanzeigen an. Oder
vielleicht auch mehr, wenn ihr noch welche habt. Wenn ihr welche habt, schickt
her.
Ich esse jetzt was, wir machen den Valomat zusammen.
Was haltet ihr davon?
Und wer sich
fragt, was ich esse,
sieht eklig aus, aber
seitdem ich regelmäßig Sport mache,
habe ich festgestellt, dass
mir das wirklich gut bekommt. Und zwar
Müsli
mit Haferflocken.
Haferflockenmüsli mit, äh,
ja, was sind das? Wie heißt das?
Blaubeeren sind das.
Haferflockenmüsli
mit bisschen bisschen
Quark und Blaubeeren.
Das sieht nicht so am
appetitlichsten aus, aber es schmeckt ganz
gut. Und ich habe gemerkt, dass
mir das bauchmäßig gut bekommt und
ähm,
ja, dass man sich
einen Tag später dann recht
gut gestärkt
anfühlt, ja.
Ist das Influencer Food? Echt
jetzt? Ist das?
Das ist Edeka Food.
Okay.
Der Warno macht.
Geh los.
Die EU soll eigene Steuern erheben dürfen.
Geh mal weg. Ich muss schon genug
Steuern bezahlen. Please no.
Ich muss schon so viel Steuern
bezahlen, Alter.
Geht mir nicht auf den Sack. Lass mich
lieber weniger Steuern bezahlen, Mann.
Wäre eine super Überleitung,
wäre ich von HelloFresh oder so
gesponsert.
Bin ich aber nicht.
Können wir eine Prediction machen?
Prediction für was?
Was beim Wahl-O-Mat rauskommt?
Ich glaube,
da gibt es 80 Parteien oder so
und eine Umfrage, eine Prediction, gibt es
plus fünf Antworten. Was soll ich denn
predikten? Ups.
Wir können eine Prediction machen, wenn ihr mir
sinnvolle
Antwortmöglichkeiten für
die, okay,
AfD ist Wahl-O-Mat optimized.
Ja, das Social Media
Gestellte haben die schon drauf.
Okay, ne, wir machen das jetzt einfach.
Also, Fahrzeuge mit
Verbrennungsmotoren
sollen auch nach
2035 in der EU neu
zugelassen werden. Ja, da bin
ich dafür, weil es durchaus
Anwendungsgebiete geben kann,
wo auch 2035
Fahrzeuge mit Verbrennungsmotoren Sinn machen
können. Ich hoffe,
wir schaffen das, dass es kaum
noch neue Fahrzeuge gibt mit Verbrennungsmotor.
Aber, keine Ahnung,
Landwirtschaft, Baumaschinen, whatever.
Es gibt sicherlich auch 2035
noch sinnvolle Anwendungsmöglichkeiten
und
Anwendungsszenarien,
die nicht mit elektrischen Sachen abgeleckt
werden können. Da stimme ich
zu. Die EU soll
eigene Seenotra...
Warum? Ich meine,
es hätte den Vorteil,
dass es eventuell
irgendwelche
Schleppersachen
einschränkt,
irgendwelche
semi-legalen
privaten Organisationen...
Vielleicht? Keine Ahnung.
Ich überspringe das, da habe ich mir viel zu wenig
Gedanken drüber gemacht, kein Schimmer.
Die Ukraine soll Mitglied der EU werden.
Das ist so eine Frage,
da wird man vielleicht
sagen...
Wie soll man sagen, so
bauchmäßig vielleicht sagen, ja,
so, fuck die Russen,
aber ich bin tatsächlich
nicht dafür, wenn man sich
überlegt, dass...
Was das für ein Stress gibt,
im Zweifelsfall, es hat sicherlich
seinen Grund,
warum die es bisher nicht geworden sind,
dass man sagt, okay, irgendwie,
dass man sich als Ziel setzt,
dass man sagt, okay, wir gucken noch mal ein paar Jahre,
aber jetzt unmittelbar
auf gar keinen Fall.
Was heißt das, wenn wir ein Land,
was gerade im Krieg ist, mit einem anderen Land in die EU aufnehmen?
Müssen wir dann irgendwie
Leute schicken,
die gegen die Russen kämpfen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt die beste
der beste Zeitpunkt ist.
Also,
in Zukunft vielleicht jetzt nicht.
Die EU soll vorrangig
ökologische Landwirtschaft fördern.
Ja, da stimme ich zu, finde ich gut.
In Deutschland soll der Euro durch eine nationale
Währung... Warum?
Der Euro ist eines der nicesten Sachen,
die wir haben. Stimme nicht zu.
Mein Ohr juckt.
Nein, ich will den Euro behalten.
Euro ist nice.
Die EU soll den Mitgliedstaaten empfehlen...
Ah, okay, es war klar, dass sowas
noch kommen muss.
Lass mich mal kurz mein Müsli weiterfuttern,
sonst bin ich nicht fertig.
Die EU soll den Mitgliedstaaten empfehlen,
außer weiblich und männlich auch die Eintragung
einer anderen Geschlechtsidentität
im Pass zu ermöglichen.
Da bin ich prinzipiell
dafür. Ich werde aber für neutral
stimmen, weil ich denke,
dass sich das die Länder selbst überlegen müssen,
ob sie das machen wollen oder nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist nichts, wo man
so von oben herab entscheiden sollte,
weil das immer super viel kontroverse
Diskussionen gibt.
Ich bin dafür, man sollte jedem
es ermöglichen, sein Leben so zu leben,
wie er will. Und wenn das dazu gehört, okay.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es
die, wie soll man sagen,
die persönliche Einstellung der Bevölkerung
ändert, wenn das die EU vorgibt.
Ich glaube, das ist nichts, was die EU vorgeben müsste.
Empfehlen heißt
für mich auch, da kommt dann irgendwas so nach
dem Motto, muss umgesetzt sein bis in drei Jahren.
Also keine Ahnung,
ich werde prinzipiell
in dem Fall für neutral.
Die Jagd auf Wölfe soll in Regionen
erlaubt sein, in denen
der Bestand dadurch nicht gefährdet ist.
Ich wusste gar
nicht, dass die Jagd auf Wölfe in Regionen
War das gar nicht klar, dass
das nicht so ist?
Also in Regionen, wo der
Bestand nicht gefährdet ist.
Warum möchte
man denn Jagd auf Wölfe machen?
Weil da irgendwelche
Bauern Schafe haben oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keinen Schimmer.
Ich putter mal mein Müsli weiter.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Ich kann mir da jetzt überhaupt keinen
Reim drauf machen.
Wölfe sind gefährlich für Bauern in der Geschichte,
sind ganze Städte verhungert.
Ich bezweifle, dass wir jetzt wegen Wölfen verhungern werden.
Ich werde das skippen, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mich da viel zu wenig mit dem
Vor und Wider und
wie gesagt, mir war bis jetzt gar nicht mal klar,
dass das überhaupt ein Ding ist.
Manche jagen for fun.
Nee, for fun bin ich nicht dafür.
Just for fun, Wölfe jagen
nicht.
Beim Bau neuer Wohngebäude in der EU
soll die Errichtung von Photovoltaik
Nein, bin ich nicht dafür.
Ich halte
es für keine gute Idee,
solche Sachen pauschal verpflichtend zu machen.
Wir sollten dahin kommen,
dass es eine gute Entscheidung ist,
dass jeder, der ein neues Gebäude baut,
Photovoltaik drauf macht.
Aber es, sag mal,
entgegen aller
finanziellen Anreize
verpflichtend zu machen,
in manchen Fällen, finde ich nicht gut.
Beim Bau neuer Wohngebäude
soll die Errichtung von... Nein.
Mehr außenpolitische Entscheidungen
der EU sollen mit Mehrheitsstadt
einstimmig getroffen werden.
Das ist keine gute Idee.
Vielleicht liege ich da...
Vielleicht verstehe ich die Frage nicht richtig,
aber überlegt mal.
Mehr außenpolitische Entscheidungen,
das sind ja so Sachen wie,
keine Ahnung,
mehr Raketen für die Ukraine,
oder sowas.
Wenn das nicht einstimmig
getroffen werden kann,
dann heißt das im Endeffekt,
die Mehrheit kann was beschließen,
aber die, die dagegen waren,
müssen es mit ausbaden.
Auf der anderen Seite,
das ist in vielen Bereichen so, ja.
RF-Programmer,
da fehlt mir immer ein bisschen Kontext
da drum herum.
Warum ist das überhaupt ein Thema gerade?
Neutral.
Was?
Der Flugzeug Treibstoffkerosin
soll für Flüge in der EU
steuerfrei sein. Nee, warum?
Warum soll der auf einmal
steuerfrei sein?
Die gemeinsame europäische
Polizeibehörde Europol
soll weit... Nein. Auf gar keinen Fall.
Ich habe die letzten Jahrzehnte erlebt,
was das heißt.
Gerade in Bezug auf...
Wir müssen
eben immer mehr Verschlüsselung reingucken.
Zertifikate
dürfen nicht mehr
generiert werden
mit Open Source Tools,
was da in letzter Zeit rumschwirrt.
Und
jegliche dieser Sachen
laufen am Ende
für irgendwie Nachteile raus.
Das wird am Anfang...
Die ganzen
Dinge, die in den letzten Jahren eingeführt sind,
werden immer eingeführt mit
Ja, wir machen das,
um schwerste Straftaten aufzuklären.
Jeder sagt, ja gut, okay.
Und dann am Endeffekt
landest du im Knast, weil
du einen USB-Stick auf dem Schulhof gegeben hast,
wo
irgendwie neueste Musik drauf ist
oder sowas.
Die EU soll länderübergreifende
mehrsprachige Angebote des
öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks stärker finanziell fördern.
Wenn dir das Beispiel zu alt ist,
dann sag halt, du schickst deinem Kumpel
über Discord irgendwas.
Wir sind die letzten Jahre über immer mehr dabei,
private Chats, Verschlüsselung
und sonst was in der Richtung zu unterbinden.
Umso mehr Befugnisse,
finde ich,
wird immer angekündigt mit
ja nur für schwerste Straftaten
und dann wird das immer weiter verwässert
über Jahre.
Okay.
Die EU soll länderübergreifende
mehrsprachige Angebote des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks
Nö.
Wisst ihr, wie viel Kohle öffentlich-rechtlicher
Rundfunk bei uns kostet?
8 Milliarden oder was kostet das?
Die bekommen so krass viel Geld
für Lilly Schönhauer
und auch alles.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass sie nicht auch sinnvolle
Sachen machen, aber da ist so viel Shit dabei.
Nö. Gibt nicht mehr Geld.
Zumindest nicht von mir.
Ich werde es eh am Ende bezahlen müssen.
Die EU soll das Ziel verwerfen,
klimaneutral zu werden.
Tja. Nö.
Sollen sie nicht verwerfen.
Das Ziel sollen sie schön behalten.
Ob sie das
einhalten werden?
Nö. Sollen sie
nicht.
Bei den Wahlen zum
Europäischen Parlament sollen die Parteien
weiterhin frei entscheiden können, wie groß
der Anteil der Geschlechter... Moment.
Ist es wirklich?
In der Diskussion
da irgendwelche Quoten einzuführen?
Die sollen einfach fähige
Leute hinschicken, Mann.
Ist ja vollkommen egal, ob die
da mehr Frauen, mehr Männer, whatever
hinschicken. Die sollen fähige Leute hinschicken.
Ja. Und wenn sie feststellen, unser
Fähigster ist
irgendwie ein Eisbär vom Nordpol,
sollen sie den hinschicken.
Ähm. Ja.
Und außerdem sollen die Parteien das...
Ups.
Die Parteien sollen das selbst entscheiden dürfen.
Ja, die können das ja auch
machen, die Parteien, ja.
Wenn manche Parteien das sagen, sie wollen das
machen, sollen sie machen. Aber die sollen das entscheiden dürfen.
Hm.
Die EU soll
Vorgaben für die Höhe der sozialen
Grundsicherung...
neutral. Ich denke, das müssen
die Länder selbst checken, was da
angemessen ist.
Wobei, dann kann ich eigentlich auch sagen, stimme nicht zu, oder?
Betreiber sozialer
Netzwerke sollen frei entscheiden dürfen, wie sie
mit Desinformation auf ihrer Plattform umgehen.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Es muss auch
Verschwörungstheorie-Plattformen geben.
Wer entscheidet,
was Desinformation ist?
Letztendlich irgendwelche Leute,
die
komischen Theorien anhängen,
treffen sich so oder so
in irgendeinem Forum, in irgendeinem Discord-Channel.
Ja.
Die Plattformen sollten das selbst entscheiden.
Ich finde tatsächlich,
und
ich lass hier letzter Zeit nicht
kaum ein gutes Haar
an Twitter.
Ich finde diese Sache tatsächlich
bei Twitter ganz gut.
Wenn man sich dort Werbung anguckt,
beispielsweise für irgendein irreführendes Mobile-Game,
wird direkt darunter
eingeblendet, Achtung,
diese Werbung ist irreführend,
enthält kein
echtes Gameplay, beziehungsweise Gameplay-Elemente,
die so nicht vorkommen.
Ich bin eh immer wieder erstaunt,
wie viele Anhänger
von Verschwörungstheorien
und Sachen es gibt,
in einer Zeit, wo es
für jeden
so einfach wie quasi in der Geschichte
nie vorher möglich war,
sich über
naturwissenschaftliche Sachverhalte
zu informieren.
Ich hab den Eindruck,
es wird den Leuten einfach zu viel.
Ich denke, die Plattformen
sollten das selbst entscheiden dürfen.
Es wird eh irgendwelche
Verschwörungstheoretiker-
Plattformen geben.
Kannste nix machen dran.
Da weißt du wenigstens, welche es sind.
Ich geb dir zum Teil recht,
aber,
Moment, richtig,
ein Problem
mit
Desinformation ist
der Blickwinkel.
Wer entscheidet,
was
als Desinformation
gilt?
Wir sind ja schon drüber hinaus,
dass man wirklich nur
ja,
harte,
quasi bewiesene
Sachen
einordnet
und dann sagt, okay,
alles, was dagegen verstößt,
ist Desinformation.
Guckt euch die ganzen Shitstorms
auf Social Media an.
Und genau
bei solchen Themen ist das
ein Problem.
Es ist ein bisschen wie,
muss ich mal den Bogen dazu spannen,
es ist ein bisschen wie
bei irgendwelchen Glaubenssachen.
Das größte Problem daran ist nicht,
dass irgendjemand irgendwie mal gesagt hat,
das ist jetzt unser heiliger Text und sowieso,
sondern, wer
interpretiert das und wer sagt,
wie das, was da steht, jetzt ausgelegt wird?
Wer hat die Deutungshoheit da drüber?
Und dementsprechend kann man sagen,
es ist gar nicht mal so klar,
in dem Fall,
was das hier genau heißt.
Und
deswegen denke ich, die Plattformen sollten das selbst
handhaben.
Es muss auch, so doof es klingt,
es muss auch einen Platz für irgendwelche
Flat Earth Leute
und sowas geben.
Natürlich ist es Schwachsinn, dass
die Erde flach ist.
Aber mir ist lieber, die machen das öffentlich
auf YouTube,
wie irgendwie
Top Secret.
Außerdem ist es lustig, sich anzugucken.
Wann sollen die Eltern ihren
Job machen
und den Leuten ein bisschen Medienkompetenz beibringen?
Das ist das gleiche,
wie Scammen im Internet.
Scammen im Internet ist an jeder Ecke.
Wichtig ist, dass man es erkennt und nicht
darauf reinfällt.
Also ich denke, die Leute, die Plattformen
sollten das selbst entscheiden dürfen.
In der EU sollen mehr Flächen als
Naturschutzgebiete ausgewiesen werden.
Ja, finde ich gut.
EU-Fördermittel für Mitgliedstaaten,
die Regeln und Werte der EU verletzen,
sollen weiterhin zurückgehalten werden.
Klingt doch erstmal sinnvoll, oder?
Wenn einer Scheiße baut,
gibt es keine Förderung.
Oder?
Mehr Naturschutzgebiete, auf wessen Kosten?
Auf meine.
Und auf deine.
Wir müssen den Scheiß am Ende eh bezahlen.
Dann passiert wenigstens was Sinnvolles mit der Kohle.
Noch mal ein Beispiel
zu der Sache
mit Disinformation.
Ihr habt doch sicherlich
alle mitgekriegt,
bleiben wir mal bei RT-Themen.
Ihr habt doch sicherlich mitgekriegt, dass es
die letzten Jahre über immer wieder
Diskussionen gibt um
Polizei möchte verschlüsselte
WhatsApp-Chats und sowas in der Richtung lesen.
Oder
nicht nur WhatsApp, also generell
Messenger-Kommunikation, Internet-Kommunikation
und sonst was.
Ist es dann Desinformation?
Wenn du oder würde es
unter Desinformation fallen
oder Fake News oder whatever,
wie auch immer man das dann nennen mag.
Wenn du auf Social Media dann her gehst
und sagst, hey,
ich empfehle euch hier
ein Plugin
für WhatsApp. Also gehen wir mal von aus,
es ist dann möglich, dass
verschlüsselte WhatsApp-Kommunikation mitgelesen werden kann.
Aber man
möchte das nicht und du postest auf
Social Media und post, ey,
mit diesem WhatsApp-Plugin, dann ist das nicht so einfach.
Könnt ihr das aushebeln?
Wird das dann als
ungewünschter Content gefleckt?
Also so klar ist
das alles nicht und
es ist immer die Frage, wer hat die
Entscheidungshoheit da drüber?
Deswegen bin ich
bei sowas immer sehr skeptisch.
Ja, witzig ist doch, das Plugin
funktioniert, aber das ist keine
gewünschte Funktionalität
von den Leuten,
die das entscheiden dürfen.
Und dann ist halt die Frage, vielleicht fällt
dann sowas auch unter Desinformation.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, wenn wir uns
noch ein bisschen länger Gedanken machen um das Thema,
fallen uns bestimmt
einige Beispiele ein, die letzten Jahre
über, wo einiges von
Desinformation
geswitcht hat zu, heute weiß man
es besser. Man wusste es
vielleicht früher schon besser. Oder
auch Themen mit,
die sind gar nicht so
klar, aber wenn man sie sagt, riskiert
man irgendeinen Shitstorm auf Social Media.
Ist das dann Desinformation?
Das ist alles nicht so einfach.
Und es hängt vieles dran,
wer die Entscheidungshoheit
bei sowas hat.
Da muss man sich unterm Strich halt fragen,
ist es einem lieber, dass
das Elon und der Zug
und sowas darüber entscheiden, wie das
auf ihrer Plattform läuft?
Oder irgendwelche EU-Politiker?
Ja,
mehr zu sagen.
Ich traue das eigentlich allen nicht zu.
Egal, machen wir mal
weiter. EU-Fördermittel für
Mitgliedstaaten. Also das klingt erstmal
für mich sehr sinnvoll. Wer Scheiße
baut, kriegt keine Förderung.
Ja, das könnte ja fast schon als
Desinformation gelten.
Okay, Chat.
Nur mal so.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich das sagen soll,
weil das super viel Shitstorm-Potential
hat. Und ich weiß, dass es auf Twitter
die letzten
die letzten Monate gab das ja
riesen Diskussionen immer.
Aber
stellt euch mal vor, wir nehmen jetzt so mal das
theoretische Beispiel.
Wenn da jemand postet, dass
eine Frau keinen Schwanz haben kann,
wird das gefleckt als
Desinformation?
Da gibt es so
ultra viel hitzige Diskussionen
drin. Würdest du das
als Desinformation flecken?
Oder nicht?
Es geht nicht um persönliche Meinungen
und sowas. Und die Frage ist,
ja,
die Frage, genau das ist
die Frage. Wer entscheidet
bei, sagen wir mal so,
unklarer Lage,
was jetzt Desinformation
sind und was nicht?
Entscheidet das jemand in der EU
oder entscheidet das da Zuck oder Elon?
Kommt drauf an, wie es gemeint ist.
Wer entscheidet?
Das ist doch das, wo es bei der Zentrale,
wo es bei dieser Frage darum geht.
Wer entscheidet? Wer hat die Deutung?
Wer hat die? Wer kann das auch?
Irgendwie auslegen.
Ist es Elon
oder ist es einer von der EU?
Das ist letztendlich, worüber man dann abstimmt.
Und
da gibt es so viele Kloppereien
auf YouTube, auf Twitch,
gerade zu diesem Thema. Das ist ja das Beste,
was mir jetzt eingefallen ist.
Was es in dem Fall
schwierig zu sagen ist.
Ich muss euch sagen, ich finde es
gar nicht so übel, wie Twitter
das zurzeit handhabt.
Nämlich mit dem Einblenden von
Informationen bei potenziellem
Schwachsinn.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll gemacht.
Oh, Alter.
Die EU soll mehr Waffen für die Ukraine
finanzieren. Boah.
Da bin ich auch so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen.
Ich denke mir immer so, ja, scheiß auf die Russen.
Macht.
Auf der anderen Seite kostet auch enorm
viel Kohle.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Die beste Variante
ist, die es wahrscheinlich nicht gibt.
Ich werde da neutral stimmen.
Ich werde es absolut nicht überspringen,
weil man muss dazu sagen, in der
Auswertung, überspringen fließt
gar nicht ein. Neutral ist
eine Antwort, die auf das, was die Parteien
sagen, matchen kann.
Die zulässige Menge an Fischen, die
in EU-Gewässern gefangen werden
dürfen,
soll gesenkt werden.
Da fehlt mir jetzt der Kontext,
wird da irgendwie krass überfischt
in EU-Gewässern?
Wenn das der Fall ist,
wäre es sicherlich sinnvoll.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich werde das überspringen,
weil ich absolut keinen
blassen Schimmer habe.
Die Einfuhrzölle
der EU auf chinesische
Elektroautos sollen erhöht werden.
Also, da muss ich ja sagen,
ich als alter China-Shopping-
Enjoyer,
finde das doof.
Ich habe jetzt allerdings nicht vor mir,
chinesisches Elektroauto zu kaufen.
Aber vielleicht in Zukunft, keine Ahnung.
Ich bestelle gerne Sachen
in China.
Und ich fände es blöd, wenn chinesische Sachen teurer
wären.
Nö. China-Chinesen-Auto.
Vielleicht in Zukunft mal, die Dinger
werden immer besser.
Der Markt regelt das, Leute.
Die EU soll sich
dafür einsetzen, dass Schwangerschaftsabbrüche
in allen Mitgliedsstrafen straffrei-
werden.
Da stimme ich zu.
Auch ein ultra
kontrovers diskutiertes Thema.
Ich kenne das aus den USA.
Dort gibt es ja ganz viele so nach
dem Motto
Schwangerschaftsabbruch gleich Mord
und sowas. In den USA ist das super krasse
vor allem so auch christlich geprägte
Diskussion. Da gibt es da so ganz viele
Pfarrer, die dann in Talkshows rum...
Übrigens auch ein Thema. Desinformation.
Egal, wo du hinguckst auf der Welt,
diese Frage
wird es
unterschiedliche Ansichten dazu geben.
Und
wenn du bei den
Amis einige fragst, sagen die
Oh ja, hier ganz böse. Also ich bin dafür.
Das sollte
überall straffrei möglich sein.
Mich
graust es quasi zu erfahren,
wenn ich diese Frage, dass das wohl
nicht überall
möglich ist.
Tja, das ist meine soziale Plattform.
Und ich würde jetzt entscheiden,
das ist eine Desinformation.
Um nochmal zu zeigen,
wie schwierig das ist mit
wer hat das Sagen, was eine Desinformation
ist und was nicht.
Ich habe jetzt entschieden, ich sitze jetzt in der EU und habe jetzt entschieden,
das was Chaka schreibt, ist eine Desinformation.
Also ich hoffe, du siehst das Problem
und das, was ich vorher versucht habe
zu erklären.
Wer die Entscheidungshoheit über solche Sachen
hat. Es sollen wieder
dauerhafte... Übrigens, das
sagt auch keiner, ne?
Das eine
extrem und das andere extrem, da geht das
überhaupt nicht.
Ja?
Es geht darum, dass das prinzipiell straffrei möglich sein soll.
Das heißt nicht, dass man sagt,
okay, dass eine
Untersuchung vorher notwendig ist,
dass eine Beratung vorher notwendig ist,
dass psychologische
Sachen vorher notwendig sind. Das sagt man überhaupt
nicht. Es geht nicht um das eine
extrem oder das andere extrem.
Es sollte meiner Meinung nach auch nicht sein,
dass man heute einfach sagen kann, ach ja,
mir ist es jetzt nicht mehr so danach.
Och nö.
Aber prinzipiell sollte das
straffrei möglich sein. Mit Auflagen.
Klar.
Dauerhafte Grenzkontrollen.
Es sollen wieder dauerhafte Grenzkontrollen...
Quatsch.
Das ist eines der besten Sachen an der EU.
Dass ich, dass ich jetzt, keine Ahnung,
nach Spanien fahren kann
oder nach Italien fahren kann, mir keiner
an der Grenze auf den Sack geht.
Na.
Will ich nicht.
Das ist eines der Hauptgründe, warum
die EU nice ist.
Die Aufnahme neuer Staaten in die EU
soll in allen Mitgliedsstaaten durch
Volksabstimmungen bestätigt werden müssen.
Ich finde,
die Musik
ist vielleicht zu solchen Dingen
nicht passend, aber...
Ich mag
sowas. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie praktikabel das ist.
Die Schweizer, die machen sowas ja gerne.
Da wird erlaufen, volksabgestimmt.
Auf der anderen Seite
hatten wir schon öfters mal Volksbefragungen.
Zum Beispiel, ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht noch dran,
Abschaffung Sommer- und Winterzeit,
wo ein
großer Teil dafür gestimmt hat.
Leider ein bisschen pepeger, weil die glaube ich
alle Winterzeit aus dem Blödsinn haben wollten.
Und es bis heute nichts passiert.
Also ich finde das
immer gut, wenn man direkt gefragt wird.
Wie praktikabel
das ist, keine Ahnung.
Brexit war auch Volksabstimmung, ja.
Haben sie den so hart.
Die EU soll den Anbau
von weiteren gentechnisch verändernden
Pflanzensorten erlauben.
Ähm...
Ist das...
Warum nicht?
Wo ist das Problem?
Ist das so diese Geschichte mit
dass dann die gentechnisch verändernden
Pflanzen quasi die
weil die besser angepasst
sind, irgendwie die normalen ausrotten
und sowas.
Klingt jetzt eigentlich erstmal was wie was, was ich
nicht haben will, aber ich kenn mich damit
viel zu wenig aus.
Was wäre da dran problematisch?
Wenn ich damit genau das gleiche
machen kann wie mit normalem Mais.
Ich glaube,
das ist ein bisschen was wie
wir setzen
Kaninchen in Australien aus.
Man wusste halt nicht genau was passiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt
gegen Frauen soll europaweit
als Asylgrund, ja finde ich gut.
Urheberrechtlich geschützte
Werke, zum Beispiel Fotos,
Musik, Literatur sollen in der EU
für nicht kommerzielle Zwecke kostenlos
verwendet werden dürfen.
Alter, das wäre geil, wenn
das geht.
Wow, kann ein Krankenwagen vorbei
gedüst.
Also ich finde das geil.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Die Sanktionen
der EU gegen Russland sollen abgebaut werden.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Da würde ich erst mal instinktiv sagen,
nein stimme ich nicht zu.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sich dann mal fragen,
schadet uns das vielleicht mehr
als es was bringt?
Das ist eine Frage, die ich nicht beantworten kann,
die ich nicht einschätzen kann.
Also mein Bauchgefühl sagt eher,
nee, scheiß auf die Russen.
Aber,
also, mir geht es bei so ziemlich
mir geht es bei so ziemlich
allen Sachen darum, wie viel Kohle
ich auf dem Konto habe.
Und ich wette mit euch,
ganz viele der Leute,
die sich auf Twitter immer
den moralischen Highground sichern,
wenn die mal nicht mehr
genug Kohle auf dem Konto haben,
dann ist ihr moralischer Highground auch ganz schnell
nichts mehr wert.
Deswegen sollte man sich mal zumindest Gedanken drüber machen,
ob sie nicht vielleicht mehr scheiß...
Ich weiß es nicht, ja.
Ähm...
Also ich tendiere
auch zu scheiß auf die Russen.
Soll nicht abgebaut werden.
Das was für ein Ding?
Das Erasmus Plus
Stipendium.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Studienaustausch...
Die EU soll Atomkraft
weiterhin als nachhaltige Energiequelle
einstufen.
Boah, das ist auch so ein Thema, ne?
Da sieht man mal,
wie viel solcher Sachen
da... Das ist auch so ein Thema.
Würde ich sagen,
sollte nicht so sein.
Auf der anderen Seite
ist die Frage,
brauchen wir es nicht vielleicht trotzdem?
Die Frage, ob man das mit alternativen
Energiequellen alles hinbekommt.
Und man fragt sich halt auch,
ob das wirklich sinnvoll ist,
wenn wir sagen jetzt zum Beispiel,
es geht ja hier um die EU, ja,
wenn wir in Deutschland sagen, ey,
wir machen das nicht mehr, kaufen das dann aber woanders,
wo es mit Atomkraft hergestellt wird.
Atomkraft kann Erneuerbare nicht ergänzen.
Warum nicht?
Klingt doch eigentlich sinnvoll, oder?
Warum geht das nicht?
Kacke für Stromnetz?
Warum?
Also, dass irgendwie das Uran ausgeht,
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Aha, okay.
Klingt einleuchten, ja.
Klingt einleuchten.
Das ist korrekt.
Atomkraft, Atomkraft.
Hier geht's
um Kernspaltung.
Was soll ich mir vorstellen?
Weil, Fusion
ist ja noch nicht wirklich
marktreif.
Wie soll man das umschreiben?
Ist das so ein Ding? Theoretisch ja.
Praktisch gebaut? Nee.
Ist das nicht so ein Meme
unter Fusionsforschern?
In 30 Jahren ist das Einsatz
bereit?
Okay, ähm,
nein.
Die Einwanderung von Fachkräften in die EU
soll vereinfacht werden.
Ja.
Wenn wir von Fachkräften reden,
die wir in Gebieten,
die wir brauchen, finde ich das nicht schlecht.
Die Frage ist,
wer zählt als Fachkraft?
Also wir hatten die letzten Jahre
schon genug Probleme in dieser Richtung.
Prinzipiell ja.
An der Umsetzung wird's wahrscheinlich
scheitern.
Also, wenn wir, das Problem
ist, also glaube ich zumindest,
ähm, dass viele Fachkräfte,
die wirklich
Fachkräfte sind, die haben gar
keinen Bock.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
ich hab mal ein Video gesehen, da war da Lindner
an irgendeiner Uni in Afrika oder so, Südafrika.
Ich glaube in Südafrika,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich glaube es war in Südafrika.
Kann aber auch ein anderes Land gewesen sein da unten.
Und da hat er einen Vortrag drüber
gehalten, wie geil es ist in Deutschland
zu arbeiten.
Und am Ende hat er gefragt,
wer von euch oder wer
von ihnen könnte sich das vorstellen, quasi
als, äh, ja,
Fachkraft nach, nach Deutschland
zu kommen. Hat sich keiner
gemeldet.
Die hatten alle keinen Bock.
Die wollten alle nicht.
Also rein, wenn man mal nur
die Frage so wertet, wie sie da steht,
ja, und mal ausplänen mit
was wird denn da draus gemacht,
finde ich, würde ich dem prinzipiell schon
zustimmen.
Also wenn das bedeutet,
wir suchen uns wirklich die Leute
raus, die wir brauchen.
Dann bin ich dafür.
Ja, aber niemals so kontrollierbar.
Naja, könnte man sicherlich, ja.
Und du brauchst halt einen nachgewiesenen
Abschluss in Sachen, die wir brauchen.
Du kannst das
sicherlich ordentlich überprüfen.
Wem, wem du da
das, ich sag mal
die Green Card gibst und wem nicht.
Wenn man, wenn man das ordentlich
gewillt ist, das ordentlich
zu machen, kann man das bestimmt.
Ich stimme der Sache zu.
Unter den Voraussetzungen,
die ich gesagt habe.
Wird doch jetzt auch nicht gemacht.
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Also wenn es wirklich so gemacht werden würde,
dann bin ich dafür.
Die Beteiligung
außereuropäischer
Investoren an Unternehmen im Bereich
kritischer Infrastruktur soll in der EU
stärker beschränkt werden.
Ja, okay.
Ich glaube, hier muss ich
echt meinem,
meiner anderweitigen
Einschätzung mal
entgegenläufig abstimmen.
Ja, da bin ich dafür,
weil ich keinen Bock habe,
dass irgendwelche China-Chinesen
bei uns
Häfen besitzen und sowas
und da machen können, was sie wollen.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt wieder sagen,
der Markt regelt das.
In dem Fall würde ich sagen,
das muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Ja.
Der Präsident
beziehungsweise die Präsidentin
der Europäischen Kommission
soll von...
Oh ja, da bin ich dafür.
Da sitzt da vielleicht irgendjemand,
auf den ich Bock habe.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht,
weil dann immer nichts Gescheites
zum Aufstellen gibt.
Aber ja, da bin ich dafür.
In der EU sollen Unternehmen
mehr für den Ausstoß von CO2
bezahlen müssen.
Mehr als woanders.
Aber man sollte es jetzt nicht
einfach komplett
übertreiben,
sodass keiner mehr hier irgendwas wirtschaftlich machen kann.
Mehr als jetzt.
Ich finde es sollte Anreize geben
und keine
irgendwelche Vorgaben.
Also
es ist schwer zu sagen,
ich kenne mich auch zu wenig in dem Bereich aus.
Ich tendiere
eher zu nein, stimme ich nicht zu.
Weil letztendlich
müssen wir den Scheiß bezahlen.
Es macht
alles wirtschaftlich problematischer.
Vermutlich.
Und außerdem
gehen die dann im Zweifelsfall
nach Bangladesch und bauen da ihren Kram hin.
Und stoßen auch nicht
weniger aus.
Ich...
Ich stimme nicht zu.
Asylbewerberinnen und Asylbewerber
sollen ihren Antrag vor Überschreiten
der EU-Außengrenze stellen müssen
und dort auf das Ergebnis warten.
Das finde ich eine sinnvolle Variante.
Das wurde ja schon vor Jahren
vorgeschlagen, mal sowas
in der Richtung einzuführen.
Da wurde das nicht weiter
verfolgt. Ich habe damals schon nicht so genau
verstanden, warum nicht.
Weil dann hast du nicht das Problem, dass wenn die Leute
erstmal am Start sind,
dass du sie niemals wieder los wirst.
Ja, das klingt sinnig.
Die EU soll weiterhin
in gemeinsame europäische Rüstungsprojekte
investieren. Ja, das ist
denke ich tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll.
Wir haben gesehen, dass es Probleme
mit Russland gibt.
So blöd ist...
So schön
die Welt wäre,
wenn man es nicht brauchen würde,
so sehr sieht man, dass man es doch braucht.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn man
sagen würde, ey, wir geben
ganz schön viel Geld
für Militär und Polizei
aus. Wäre es nicht geil,
wenn wir das sonst sparen können?
Du hast halt immer ein paar Leute,
die finden es halt geil,
wenn es keine Polizei mehr gibt.
Und sie ihr Zeug treiben können.
Die Realität
und Wirklichkeit passen halt nicht zusammen.
Ich glaube, man sieht
aktuell, dass es doch nicht so friedlich
auf der Welt ist, wie wir das gerne hätten.
Deswegen hier gut vorbereitet zu sein, ist
sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Per Fax natürlich.
Mit was denn sonst?
In Deutschland geht sowas nur per Fax.
Ahem.
Das Europäische Parlament
soll weiterhin eine zentrale Rolle...
Ja, da würde ich tatsächlich zustimmen, weil
was sonst?
Okay.
Gewichtung der Thesen.
Wir gewichten gar nichts.
Wir lassen uns einfach default.
Alle.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da dann rauskommt.
Ihr Wahl-O-Mata-Games.
Die Basis.
Die Basis wurde im Umfeld gegen staatliche Maßnahmen
der Covid-Pandemie gegründet.
Ach du Scheiße, Mann!
Der 5G-Technologie-
Jensi-Kritisch-Gang.
Scheint aber sonst ganz brauchbare
Ansichten zu haben, oder?
Gagalo.
Damit hätte ich wirklich nicht gerechnet,
Mann. Das ist mein bester Match,
gegen welche 5G-Gegner sind, Mann.
Ach du Scheiße, Alter.
Die Partei auch am Start.
Okay. FD...
PDF.
Die Partei des Fortschritts.
Aha.
Bündnis-Deutschland.
Ach die, okay.
Menschliche Welt.
Die Piraten.
Gibt's noch? Die habe ich früher öfters gewählt.
Also, als die noch gab.
Irgendwie.
Freie Wähler.
Der Markt regelt das. Hätte mich auch gewundert,
wenn die nicht weiter oben mit am Start sind.
Der Markt hat geregelt.
Die Linke.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich
so viele Zustimmungen mit denen habe, okay.
Tierschutz hier.
Ja, das ist ja wenigstens was, was ich unterschreiben würde.
Was das heißt?
Oh, ne. Nur 65% Linke
Twitter.
Twitter-Shitstorm.
Eshaft jetzt?
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich hätte
bei einer Partei
Tierschutz
als letztes an sowas gedacht.
Wie kommst du da drauf,
dass das so ist?
ÖDP.
Ökologisch-Demokratie.
Was es alles gibt, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Familie, Heimat, Meer.
Die sind auch am Start.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es die jetzt auch
als Partei gibt.
Tierschutzpartei.
Na gut, hier unten ist er.
Guck mal.
AfD ist auch ganz unten mit am Start.
Ja, die Punkte habe ich bestimmt
gesammelt mit
an der Grenze
bereits den Antrag
einreichen.
Okay.
Also, Leute,
ich muss die
5G-Leugner, äh,
ne, die 5G-Kekalo-Leute
wählen laut dem Wahl-O-Mat, Mann.
Da hätte ich echt nicht mit gerechnet,
ey, dass ich auf, dass die
meiste Zustimmung irgendwelche
Technologie-Typen sind, ey.
What the fuck?
Richtig kekalo, Mann.
Die mögen auch nicht Bill Gates.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das passt ja zu dem.
Nicht zwangsläufig.
Ähm. Nicht zwangsläufig.
Ich meine,
es geht ja um EU-Grenze,
nicht um Landesgrenze. Das heißt ja nicht, dass sie
nicht woanders hin können,
wo es erstmal safe ist
und dort dann den Antrag stellen.
Also, da gibt es keine wirklich
perfekte Lösung.
Irgendjemand fällt leider immer hinten runter.
Und wenn man es selbst ist.
Was ist Mera25? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung.
Gemeinsam für europäische Unabhängigkeit.
What?
Alter, hör mir auf.
Es geht mir so am Arsch vorbei.
Ich wusste bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
wo auf Twitter
geschitzt worden wurde, mit Ach und Krach,
wer Anni the Duck überhaupt, oder Annie?
Ich wusste mit Ach und Krach erstmal,
wer das überhaupt ist.
Irgendjemand ist ja auf Twitch streamt.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht.
Ich weiß übrigens immer noch nicht genau, was das Problem ist.
Ich habe mich damit null beschäftigt.
Ich will das auch gar nicht wissen.
Ich glaube, sie hat gesagt, ihre Fans stinken und sie mag ihre Fans nicht.
Was ich voll und ganz verstehen kann.
Ich würde die meisten Fans da aber sicherlich auch nicht mögen.
Und ansonsten,
wahnsinnige Überraschung.
Influencer
behaupten Dinger, um gut
da zu stehen, stehen aber nicht dahinter.
Wer hätte das nur denken können?
Niemals.
Niemals hätte man da drauf kommen können.
Nie.
Das ist alles immer schon so super authentisch
und immer glaubwürdig.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da abgeht.
Und das Statement
habe ich mir nicht angeguckt,
weil mich schon das ursprüngliche Problem
oder was heißt Problem?
Das ursprüngliche
Ärgernis für viele Leute
ging mir schon am Arsch vorbei.
Und das jetzt geht mir noch mehr am Arsch vorbei.
Was ist
PTBS?
Und ist das wirklich was,
was irgendwelche öffentlichen
Leute, die nicht dabei waren auf Twitter
jetzt alles so genau
wissen und einschätzen und
dazu was sagen müssen, ja?
PTSD, ja.
Der einzige Grund, warum da
jeder drauf reacted ist,
weil das im Prinzip
genau das gleiche, weil das Kohle, äh,
na Kohle, sagen wir mal,
Exposure.
Bringt.
Indirektkohle.
Es ist mir sowas von
scheißegal,
wer da mit wem irgendwas hatte,
wer da wen irgendwie beschissen hat,
es ist mir sowas von egal.
Ich gebe zu,
einen gewissen Unterhaltungswert haben diese
Influencer-Beefs immer
so am Rande mitverfolgt.
Was ich auch immer super unterhaltsam fand
die letzten, ähm,
Monate, war
diese Geschichte,
Joker vs. KuchenTV,
da musste ich mich auch öfters wegkacken,
wenn ich da manche Sachen zu gelesen hab.
Also,
ja, es stimmt,
ein bisschen, gewissen
Unterhaltungswert hat dieser ganze
Kram schon.
Ähm,
aber
nicht genug, als dass ich mich
im Detail mit
der ganzen Sache zu sehr beschäftigen will.
Was ich besonders lustig
an dieser anderen, an dieser KuchenTV
vs. Shoryoka Sache fand, ist,
dass sie sich auch
gegenseitig
verklagt haben.
Wo dann immer wieder kam,
jetzt kam ein Brief vom Anwalt,
dann kam das nächste Video,
ich hab Post
vom Anwalt bekommen.
Mein Anwalt hat jetzt drauf geantwortet.
Dann kam wieder ein Video drauf,
Post vom Anwalt.
Was?
Oh Mann.
Wer gönnt sich richtig mit sowas, ey?
Ja, ihr habt recht,
einen gewissen Unterhaltungswert hat der ganze
Influencer-Brief-Kram schon.
Aber mich interessiert es nicht,
nicht genug, was ich mir das im Detail
angucken will.
Und, jetzt passiert es hier.
Ohne darüber
mich im Detail informiert zu haben.
Wenn wir das Influencer
vor der Kamera
gut Wetter machen, und
hintenrum sich
kacke verhalten, und vielleicht nicht
die Menschen sind, die man
gerne in ihnen sehen möchte,
ist wirklich echt nichts Neues.
So. Ich bin fertig
essen, können uns jetzt die restlichen Stellenanzeigen
angucken. Ah, noch zwei, äh,
drei Stück. Vier Stück.
Das hatte ich doch schon, oder?
Wer weiß.
Aber,
nachdem das hier meine Plattform ist,
kann ich einfach als Desinformation
flaggen, was ich will.
Und, das ist natürlich
alles faken, just dann.
Ja. Vielleicht bin ich auch Agile-Coach.
Das könnte sein. Also.
Let's go. Was haben wir hier?
DevOps-Engine. Das ist mir auf jeden Fall schon
mal viel zu hell, diese Seite. Und,
das erste, was mir auffällt ist,
die haben viel zu viele Anzüge an.
Was ist da los?
Als DevOps-Engine. Die sehen viel,
viel, viel, viel zu business enterprise
aus. Scheint ja nicht
so richtig menschlich zu sein, ne?
Die menschliche Welt.
Der Typ im Hintergrund ist doch aus Mr. Robot.
Du meinst den da?
Vielleicht ein ganz kleines
bisschen, ja? Vielleicht
ein ganz kleines bisschen.
Äh, äh, von der Frisur
vielleicht ein bisschen. Ich hab, wie hieß
dieser, wie hieß denn der Typ bei Mr. Robot?
Der, äh,
der Manager, der ein bisschen IT-Ahnung hatte.
Wo sie leider
meiner Meinung nach das Ende von Season 1
voll verkackt haben.
Der, äh, der Elliot
am Anfang gefragt hat, benutzt du schon
Gnome oder noch KDE?
Oder irgendwie so komisches Zeug.
Warte mal, Mr. Robot, KDE?
Das, dieser Dialog hat
so keinen Sinn gemacht, aber
ja.
Ja.
Oh, hi.
Tyrell Willick.
Tyrell. Genau.
Elliot.
Just attacked.
Don't be so humble.
You know, I started out exactly
where you are, and to be honest,
you know, my heart is still there.
So I see a running Gnome.
You know, I'm actually
on KDE myself.
I know this desktop environment
is supposed to be better, but
you know what they say, old habits,
they die hard.
An executive running Linux?
That's what you're thinking.
I'm an executive, I mean,
why am I even running Linux?
Again, old habits.
Eigentlich kann die Firma gar nicht so schlecht sein,
wenn man, wenn sie freie Betriebssystem,
wenn sie freie Betriebssystemwahl
hat.
Okay.
Also, da sind wir hier
am Start.
Ja, ein bisschen vielleicht.
Für unsere Abteilung in der
Information im Standort suchen wir einen
DevOps Engineer, MWD in Vollzeit,
ihr vielfältiges Aufgabengebiet
umfasst unter anderem
Management und Optimierung von
Tools, Standards und Prozessen
in der Automatisierung von
Bereitstellungsprozessen.
Develop, Build and Run.
Aha.
Deployed wird nicht.
Das ist
nicht im Scope.
Lösung neuer technischer Herausforderungen
in der Softwareentwicklung, Schnittstelle
zwischen IT-Infrastruktur, IT-Anwendungsentwicklung,
aktive Mitwirkung in klassischen oder agilen IT-Projekten.
Okay, das ist sehr nichtssagend.
Was machst du
die ganze Zeit mit der Uhr?
Das ist mein Pro-Hackerman-Move.
Ihr Profil.
Abgeschlossenes
Studium
der Wirtschaftsinformatik
oder eine vergleichbare
Ausbildung.
Praktische
Erfahrung im Aufbau von DevOps-Umgebung.
Ah, das ist hier
genau meins.
Ich hab schon DevOps
gemacht bevor es das Wort DevOps gab.
Boomer Talk.
Praktische Erfahrung
in der Softwareentwicklung.
Ich hab vor allem Erfahrung
im entwickeln fehlerfreier Software.
Wie man hier sieht.
Keine Bugs.
Hier mal
eine Stelle.
Moment.
Sind das nicht die Abmahnkanzlei?
Ne, die guck ich mir
aus Prinzip nur hier im Stream an.
Alles Anwenderfehler.
Korrekt.
Sicherer Umgang im
Source Control Management.
Shitlab.
Und CI, CD,
Jenkins, Gitlab,
JFrog Artifactory.
Ich kenne witzigerweise alles.
Und ich mag
Jenkins. Auch wenn Jenkins
für viele oldschool ist.
Irgendwie hab ich ein Herz
für Jenkins.
Ein Herz für Nagios hab.
Auch wenn ich keinen neuen Nagios mehr installieren möchte.
Praktische Erfahrungen mit Einsatz von
Ansible. Ja passt da gut dabei.
Erfahrung
in der Bereitstellung von
Containern, Docker,
Kubernetes.
Wir müssen alles
cool aussprechen, dass wir auch hier
als Experten rüberkommen.
Deswegen Chat.
Wie sprecht ihr das hier aus?
Wie wird das hier aus?
Wie wird das hier ausgesprochen?
Jason?
An
Jason denkt keiner oder?
Warum nicht
Jason?
Das ist das was du meinst.
Sogar der
Jason Erfinder sagt es wird
Jason ausgesprochen.
Wobei er das glaube ich nur
ich weiß nicht ob er das wirklich ernst gemeint hat.
Erfahrung im Monitoring.
Grafena.
Grafana.
Prometheus.
Oder wie die Amis sagen Prometheus.
Erfahrung
mit Datenbank.
Oracle, Postgres, Exasol.
Ich hab legit kein blassen Schimmer was
Exasol ist.
The In-Memory-Database.
Okay. Kennt das jemand von euch?
Nie gehört.
Erfahrung im Datenbank Refactoring,
Versioning, Liquibase.
Flyway kenn ich. Aber
wahrscheinlich das gleiche.
Ausgeprägtes
analytisches Denkvermögen
und konzeptionelle Fähigkeiten.
Starke Kommunikationsfähigkeit,
Teamfähigkeiten, Eigeninitiative.
Wer sind wir?
Wir sind eine unabhängige Privatbank mit
Hauptsitz in Hamburg. Schön für euch.
Müssen wir jetzt nicht durchlesen.
Das individuelle
Betreuung unserer Kunden. Sehr gut im
Arbeitsklima unserer überschaubaren Unternehmenskurse.
Okay. Eine Sache
die mir tatsächlich schon mal positiv.
auffällt ist,
dass das was sie suchen
und das was sie schreiben
ziemlich gut übereinstimmt.
Das ist ja auch nicht gegeben
bei jeder Stellenanzeige.
Das ergibt schon mal in sich
konsistent so geschlossen irgendwie Sinn.
So.
Wir bieten attraktive Vergütung. Ja dann sag doch mal.
Sag doch mal eine Hausnummer.
Ich finde das immer so geil.
Überdurchschnittliche Vergütung.
Ein überdurchschnitt- oder marktübliches
Gehalt. Attraktive Vergütung.
Ja was denn? Sagt halt mal was.
Und sei es nur eine Range.
Sagt halt mal was.
Attraktive Vergütung kann jeder sagen.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten und mobiles
Arbeiten. Schön, dass
es da steht.
Mobiles Arbeiten vor allem.
Mobiles Arbeiten ist der
Überbegriff, wo unter anderem
Homeoffice auch drunter fällt.
Also ich meine es sind zwei unterschiedliche
Varianten.
Aber viele Unternehmen haben eine mobile
Arbeiten Regelung, wo dann Homeoffice
auch drunter fällt.
Zentral
gelegene Arbeitsplatz mit
optimaler Anbindung an die öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln.
Glaube ich Ihnen jetzt einfach mal.
Individueller Förderlohn.
30 Tage Urlaub, Weihnachten, Silvester
frei. Kommt das da zu? Oder musst
ihr den Urlaub nehmen?
Ich würde mal sagen zusätzlich. Also bei uns ist es auch so.
Weihnachten, Silvester ist zu, da musst ihr keinen
Urlaub nehmen. Betriebliche Altersvorsorge
und vermögenswirksame
Leistungen. Dienstleistungen
und Betragsleasing. Das haben auch sehr
viele Bezugsvermittler.
Das ist
es ist echt ein großer Vorteil eine
Kantine drinnen zu haben, die
subventioniert wird.
Vor allem wenn das Essen gut ist.
Das ist echt ein Vorteil.
Interessiert.
Finde ich gar nicht übel.
Weiß nicht ob derjenige noch am Start ist, der es gepostet hat.
Finde ich jetzt gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich meine es ist jetzt nicht so, wo ich sage
beste Anzeige die ich hier gesehen habe, aber
finde ich geht klar.
Sieht man noch wer es
gepostet hat? Ne.
Keine Ahnung. Ich finde geht
klar. Next.
ZEVdesk.
Echt? Keine Ahnung.
ZEV, war das
eben nicht noch auf deutsch?
Ne.
Also.
ZEVdesk.
Intuitive Cloud Accounting
Software bla bla bla.
Your Mission.
Sie suchen einen
Technical Lead.
Frontend JavaScript React.
Ein Tech Lead im
Frontend Development.
Focus on Web Development.
Hätte ich jetzt
in das erste ehrlich gesagt schon reininterpretiert.
Your
Mission is to drive the
conversion of potential
Customer. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist ja der krasseste Business Speak
aller Zeiten, Alter.
Your Mission is to drive the
Conver... Ich dachte eigentlich du bist
Technical Lead für Frontend Entwicklung.
Und nicht irgendwelche Leute zu überzeugen
den Scheiß zu kaufen.
Das sind jetzt zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, die ich da...
Egal. Aber das ist ja mal hier.
Your Mission is to drive the conversion of
potential customers to various
marketing touchpoints.
Ensuring they are
convinced of the product to the extent that
they are willing to initiate trial phase...
Im Prinzip wollen die in Frontend
Tech Lead Entwickler, der aber gut
verkauft?
Oder wie?
Oder was? Oder wollen die
dass... dass der sich drum
kümmert, dass man
eine gute...
Wie nennt man das?
So eine gute...
Wie heißt das denn? Wenn man...
So eine Art Landing Page oder sowas.
Ja genau. Ja.
So eine Art Landing Page
bauen, dass die Leute Bock haben sich das
weiter anzugucken.
Und du brauchst natürlich das passende
Grindset-Mindset, sonst geht da gar nichts.
Okay.
So macht man Impact.
Man actively
contributed
to the continuous improvement
and optimization of our website.
Okay. Also.
Man erweitert
und programmiert an der Website herum.
In Ordnung. Du hattest auch noch
eine. Weiß nicht, ob ich die heute alle noch durchkrieg.
Man supportet
die Marketingleute
mit dem
Webflow...
Mit der Web... Was? In managing our
Webflow-based Website
and integrate our custom Toolkits.
Also man...
Man macht ein bisschen Support
für das... für die... für die
Marketingleute.
Dass sie in ihrem, ja...
Content-Management-System da
Dinger machen können oder so.
Whatever.
Man maint...
Okay. Man wartet und verbessert
existing tracking... Tracking-Setups meinen
die wahrscheinlich sowas wie Google Analytics in der
Richtung vermutlich.
Oder?
Was ist mit Tracking-Setup in dem
Fall gemeint? Ja.
Indem man seine High-IQ
super krasses Knowledge nutzt,
was Rest-APIs angeht.
Whatever das damit zu tun hat.
Und NoSQL-Database
is like MongoDB.
Ja. Okay.
So. Man hilft
dabei interne Marketing-Tools
zu verbessern.
Content-Management. Hier kann ich aber nicht merken
was es heißt. Tracking-Systeme.
Man übersetzt
von Nicht-Technik-Leuten
zu Technik-Geschichten.
You implement Marketing-Technology.
Tech-Management-Systems. Tracking-Scripts.
Du bist halt
im Endeffekt ein Frontend-Entwickler.
Der sich noch um
bisschen anderen Kram mit kümmert.
Okay. Man ist
besonders passionate
für Coding und
möchte da mitarbeiten.
High-Quality-Efficient-Code-Delivery.
Okay. Alles klar.
Was soll man denn können?
Fünf Jahre Erfahrung
in modernen JavaScript-Frameworks.
Wie zum Beispiel React, Gatsby,
Next...
Gatsby nicht so ein Blogging-System?
Ah ne. Das ist React.
Was meine ich denn für ein Blogging-System?
Das heißt doch,
ich meine nicht Hugo.
Es gibt doch noch ein anderes.
Ist das nicht so ähnlich?
Dann weiß ich nicht.
Okay. Next.js, Express.js.
Also einfach nur sagen,
Express.js ist alles, bloß nicht neu.
Okay. Sagen wir auch modern.
Or Node.js.
Wait a minute. Leute.
Step back.
Nur weil es JS am Ende hat,
ist Node.js ganz was anderes
als Next.js und React
Das ist alles JavaScript-Frameworks.
Das ist JavaScript-Runtime.
Da ist zwar auch JS am Ende.
Das ist aber was komplett anderes.
Was ist denn Webflow?
Ja so ganz genau checke ich das auch nicht.
Ich vermute mal,
dass die halt irgendwelche internen
Marketing-Tools haben.
Vielleicht irgendwie mit so
irgendwelchen Workflow-Sachen
zum Durchklicken und
ja da sollst du denen helfen bei.
Ghost. Meine ich Ghost?
Das kann sein.
Das muss man ja bei denen echt lassen.
Tracking ist denen
enorm wichtig, oder?
Tracking kommt irgendwie in jedem
zweiten Satz vor.
Ja man kennt sich aus
mit Cookie, mit diesen Zustimmungs-Cookie,
Zustimmungs-Bannern. Tracking
Scripts
und AB-Testing.
Aha.
Ja.
Webflow ist eine No-Code
SaaS-Website-Bilder.
Okay. Nie gehört.
Also.
AB-Testing.
Heißt so viel wie
man macht zwei
Webseiten-Versionen und dann
lässt man
ja wie auch immer
überprüfen welche
besser performt.
Das hatten sie schon mal.
Man soll fluent in German und Englisch sein.
Damit
nachlose Kommunikation mit dem Team
und across Departments gewährleistet
werden kann.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Jopscript, React, REST,
Docker.
SQL, AWS, Terraform.
Tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Guck mal hier.
Das dürfte, glaube ich, vielen
Enterprise
Programmers gefallen.
Viele Java-Entwickler
stehen auf Spring Boot. Nur viele
Java-Entwickler stehen eigentlich nicht mehr
so richtig auf Java.
Und die Kombination aus
Spring Boot könnte, könnte ich mir
zumindest vorstellen, in diesem Ökosystem
tatsächlich einige
ansprechen.
Javascript ist klar, weil Frontend,
React, halt REST einfach mal so
Worte eingefügt.
Docker, wie auch immer.
SQL, AWS, also Amazon
und Terraform.
Für Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Klingt doch eigentlich alles ganz sinnig.
CDK, Terraform.
CDK ist Terraform.
War CDK nicht diese Geschichte mit
Nicht, dass ich es gerade
durcheinanderbringe.
War CDK nicht
diese Geschichte von
HashiCorp, also quasi auch die
Terraform-Entwickler
beziehungsweise Terraform-Hersteller,
dass du quasi
Wie kann man das sagen?
Deine Terraform-Config-
Templaten kannst im Endeffekt.
Du
kannst quasi in
normalen Programmiersprachen
War das nicht?
Klingt das jetzt durcheinander?
Nee, CDK vor Terraform,
das meine ich doch.
Das meine ich doch, genau.
Genau, man kann normale Programmiersprachen
benutzen.
Quasi um seine Terraform
zu templaten.
Es ist ja nicht wirklich
Terraform, wie heißt das?
HCL oder sowas
da rauskommt, aber es benutzt
im Prinzip den gleichen Kram.
Aber nachdem es quasi nur Templating
ist, bedeutet das auch
und das ist das, was mich an CDK
ein bisschen abgeschreckt hat, du kannst da keine
Runtime-Logik
in CDK machen. Also du kannst
jetzt beispielsweise nicht sagen, ey
ich lasse
meine Servernamen für
die VM
dynamisch während der Ausführzeit
von meinem
Infrastructure as Code generieren von
sagen wir mal irgendeinem zentralen
Asset Management oder so.
Das ist quasi nicht, das ist quasi nur so zur
zur Build Time.
Du kannst quasi dann
Terraform templaten und am Ende fällt halt
ein fertiges Bundle raus,
was du dann ausführen kannst
gegen einen Cloud-Anbieter und dann wird
deine Infrastruktur aufgebaut.
Zum Zeitpunkt des
Appliance auf der Infrastruktur läuft da
nichts Dynamisches mehr in Python oder JavaScript.
Das ist das, was ich ein bisschen
doof fand an CDK.
Wundert mich, dass das sowas noch keiner
gebaut hat. Auch mit Pulumi ist das
schwierig.
Was sage ich dazu?
Ich glaube, das könnte ganz nice sein.
Gerade für Leute, die auf das hier stehen.
Steht halt nichts dazu da, was
Gehalt und so angeht.
Zumindest sehe ich das jetzt hier nicht.
Also das ein bisschen
betriebliche Altersvorsorge
kriegst, wo die
30 Euro, das ist jetzt aber nicht gerade
viel.
Keine Ahnung.
Klingt jetzt nicht schlecht.
Kann ich nicht einschätzen.
Klingt stimmig.
Ausflippen tue ich
jetzt nicht.
Ich habe mich gerade gewundert, was das ist.
Nein, es geht jetzt gar nichts an.
Das hatten wir ja vorhin.
So.
Haben wir noch die hier.
Zeige ich mal her.
Systemadministrator MWX.
Mache einen Unterschied
unserem dynamischen Team.
Mir du Dankeschön für den Sub und sorry Leute.
Ich glaube, es gab heute nicht viele, aber ich glaube,
ich habe euch übersehen.
Treudel, danke schon für den Sub.
Gar nicht gecheckt.
Darkseid auch wieder am Start.
Ja, verkackt.
Nicht gesehen.
Okay, die haben schon mal ganz nice Farbverläufe
hier unten.
Das Allerwichtigste in so einer
Stellenanzeige.
Nice Gradients.
Discover to manage.
Alles klar.
Deine Aufgaben.
Dein Systemadministrator MWX.
Deine Aufgaben bei RayNet.
Installation, Konfiguration, Wartung von
Hardware und Softwarekomponenten.
Oh ja.
Eine AfD-Stellenausschreibung
als PDF.
Immerhin, das muss man niederlassen,
immerhin als PDF.
Und nicht als
Doc oder sowas.
Es ist ein Wordpress.
Guck mal, ganz viele verwenden Wordpress.
Wundert mich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was wir haben für Wordpress.
Administration
von Windows- und Linux-Systemen.
Das finde ich schon mal immer eine
fragwürdige Entscheidung.
Weil ernsthaft,
ich kenne kaum einen richtig guten Linux-Admin,
der Bock hat, Windows-Systeme zu administrieren.
Und umgedreht ist es witzigerweise
auch oft so,
dass so die ganzen Hardcore-Windows-Leute
wenig
Bock auf Linux haben.
Allerdings muss ich sagen, es kommt öfters vor
als umgedreht.
Ich kenne öfters Windows-Leute,
die sich auch für Linux interessieren.
Wahrscheinlich, weil Windows so scheiße ist.
Windows-Server.
Allerdings sehe ich sehr wenige Linux-Leute,
die da gut sind
und zufrieden damit sind,
die sich gleichzeitig auch für Windows-Server interessieren.
Ich bin, glaube ich, das beste Beispiel
für, ich lasse ja keine Gelegenheit aus,
gegen Windows-Server zu flamen.
Ich würde im Leben nichts mit
Windows-Server machen.
Linux only, kein Windows-Server.
Ich kenne aber einige Windows, aber
bei uns auch gerade auf der Arbeit,
die sich selbst auch ein bisschen
mit Linux-Systemen beschäftigen.
Aber beides in einem
gibt es nicht. Ganz ehrlich,
gibt es nicht. Wenn du gescheite Leute haben willst,
gibt es nicht.
Sicherstellung des Laufens des Betriebs durch
Überwachung und Optimierung der Systemleistung.
Ah ja, das ist auch sehr allgemein geschrieben.
Die Tools wären da mal ganz interessant.
Verwaltung von Nutzerkonten und Zugriffsrechten.
Ja, Windows-AD geschützt halt.
Managen von aktuellen Microsoft-
Windows-Azure-Exchange.
Teams, alter.
Ausbau, Wartung, Optimierung
der LAN- und WLAN-Netzwerke
über alle Standorte hinweg.
Oh, das wird so eine eierlegende
Wollmilchsau-Anzeige, glaube ich, langsam.
Oder?
Installation, Konfiguration, Wartung
Hardware-Software-Komponenten.
Monitoring.
Benchmark-Gedöns.
Windows, Linux.
Azure Exchange, Sharepoint.
Benutzerrechte.
Netzwerk.
Gewährleistung einer
sicheren und effizienten Vernetzung
aller Standorte.
Patch-Management.
Netzwerk-Monitoring.
Konfiguration, Überwachung und Datensicherung.
Backup.
Storage, eventuell auch noch mit dran.
First- und Second-Level-Support.
Da muss ich tatsächlich
schon mal den anderen rausholen.
Schwachstellen.
Ach so, ach ja, das auch noch.
Penetration-Testing.
Sicherheitsupdate.
First- und Second-Level-Support.
Mitarbeiter in Übernahme
von internen und kundenspezifischen Projekten.
Alles klar.
Anforderungsanalyse, Planung,
Konfiguration, neue Systeme zu optimieren.
Dokumentation.
Also, seriously, was ist denn das schon wieder?
Wir hatten das geschrieben, Mann.
Die Ein-Mann-IT-Abteilung ist wieder unterwegs.
Suchen die vielleicht fünf verschiedene
Leute.
Was du mitbringen solltest.
Zweierberufserfahrung.
Kenntnisse.
IT-Infrastruktur.
Komponenten.
Server, Switches, Firewalls.
Pondierte Kenntnisse im Bereich Microsoft.
Nope.
Pondierte Kenntnisse in Windows-Clients.
Kenntnisse im Bereich
IP, Routing, Proxy,
DNS, DHCP.
Okay.
Da hat irgendjemand
mal schnell gegoogelt
oder Chat-GPT
gefragt.
Ach, Moment, Moment.
Vmware, Proxmox, HP.
Ach, das auch noch.
Das auch noch. Ja, logisch.
Container, Kubernetes.
Ja, klar.
Na, klar. Hat ja noch
gefehlt.
Machst du noch Kubernetes-Administration nebenbei.
Erfahrung
Baracuda Firewall.
Kenn ich nicht.
VPN.
Umfeld.
Kenntnisse in PowerShell. Anderen Skript schon
ausgewiesen. Soziale
Kompetenz. Also, wenn die irgendjemanden finden, der das
alles kann, dann ist der alles bloß nicht soziale
kompetent. Offener, professioneller
und stets lösungsorientierter Kommunikationsstil.
Was dich erwartet.
Viel Platz für eigenverantwortliches Handeln.
Okay, heißt so viel wie, wir haben keinen Plan, wir machen
einfach mal, aber du kriegst den Anschiss, wenn's nicht
geht.
Meine Interpretation des Ganzen.
Flache Hierarchien,
direkte Ansprechpartner.
Ja, direkte Ansprechpartner, die dann mit den Schultern zucken.
Vielleicht tu ich ihnen jetzt aber auch
unrecht, aber die Stellenanzeige ist
nicht gut. Team-Events und
Work-Life-Balance. Moment, Team-Events
gehen gerade gegen Work-Life-Balance.
Junges, dynamisches
Team in einem modernen Büro.
Individuelle Weiterbildungswahl,
Einspruchswachstum.
Hauseigenes Fitnessstudio bezahlen.
Okay.
Was ihn abstellt, kann man
mit dem Gewicht drinnen.
Und die Sauna, da drinnen wird's
einfach heiß, weil's kein Fenster hat.
85 Meter
große Dachterrasse, Panoramablick.
Ladesäulen für, das find ich cool.
Vergünstigungsrabatte
über Bitkom.
Das haben sauviele.
Kaffeetier- und Wasserflatrate. Okay, nice.
Okay.
Ich kann nichts über
Reynard selbst sagen.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass das hier
eine super nice Stelle ist, aber wie ich
hier so oft in diesem Video sag, wir müssen
die Unternehmen, wenn man sie nicht kennt, danach beurteilen,
was die Stellenanzeige für einen Eindruck macht.
Genauso wie das umgedreht ist, wenn man sich dort
bewirbt, der erste Eindruck zählt.
Und die Stellenanzeige ist schlecht.
Viel reinschreiben.
Ungleiche gute
Stellenanzeige.
Ich find die...
Würdet ihr euch drauf bewerben, wenn ihr aus
Paderborn kommt? Hättet ihr Bock drauf?
Was sind deine
Verbesserungsvorschläge? Ist mein Arbeitgeber...
Okay. Also.
Erstmal würde ich eingrenzen, was
man eigentlich sucht. Also wenn
ihr wirklich jemanden sucht,
der das hier alles kann, das ist aussichtslos.
Ihr findet niemand,
der Virtualisierung, Storage,
Netzwerk,
Kubernetes, Cloud,
Microsoft,
Windows Zeug, Active Directory
und Linux kann. Das könnt ihr
vergessen.
Das gibt's nicht.
Zumindest nicht, wenn er sich damit auch ordentlich
auskennen soll. Das gibt's
einfach nicht.
Und, und. Also. Als erstes würde
ich mir ernsthaft überlegen, muss der First und
Second Level Support machen?
Weil so ziemlich alle wirklich fähigen Leute,
die das... sind mega abgeschreckt
von First Level Support.
Und wenn es nicht wirklich klassischer First Level
Support ist, das ist tatsächlich echt ein Tipp,
den können wir vielleicht...
Kannst du vielleicht was damit anfangen?
Wenn es nicht klassischer First Level Support
ist, dann schreib das
auch anders rein.
Weil wenn ich First Level Support lese,
da bin ich instant abgeschreckt.
First Level
Support für mich heißt,
mich ruft
keine Ahnung, Gertrude aus der
Personalabteilung an
und sagt, auf meinem Monitor
sind so komische Dinger drauf,
was mach ich denn jetzt?
Was kam beim Valomat
raus? Alter,
beim Valomat kam raus, ich soll
irgendwelche
Verschwörungstheorie 5G
Leute, 5G
Skeptiker
wählen, ey.
Übernehmen eh die Azubis.
Da muss ich jetzt
auch mal dazu sagen, nur im
First Level Support sitzen ist jetzt auch keine gute
Ausbildung und schreckt eher ab.
Also wenn ihr eure Azubis behalten wollt,
vielleicht
nicht unbedingt immer in First Level Support
stecken, sonst hauen die euch ab.
Niemand macht geile First Level Support. Wobei, kann man
nicht sagen, es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die machen das gerne.
Ja.
Aber ansonsten, ganz ehrlich,
wenn ihr wirklich ernsthaft jemanden sucht,
der das alles kann, das könnt ihr
vergessen.
Das muss
präziser sein und
besser auf das passen. Wenn ihr jemanden sucht, der
Linux hat, dann fokussiert euch
auf den Linux-Bereich
und baut das hier. Da könnt ihr dann durchaus auch so Sachen
hier wie Netzwerk und
ähm...
mit ruhig reinnehmen, weil das eher was ist
im Linux-Schwerpunkt.
Wenn ihr jemanden eher
sucht, der sich mit Microsoft-Technologien
auskennt, dann lasst
das Linux-Zeug
raus. Also
das muss ein bisschen, aus meiner
Sicht zumindest, das muss ein bisschen
ja... runtergebrochen
werden eigentlich.
Und letztendlich ist das ja auch nicht eine
Person, muss man auch ehrlich sagen.
Also wenn ihr das wirklich alles braucht,
braucht ihr, würde ich mal sagen, mindestens
zwei. Ihr braucht einen, der richtig
gut ist, was Microsoft-Sachen angeht. Ihr braucht
einen, der richtig gut ist, was Linux-Sachen angeht.
Und eventuell, je nachdem
wie sehr es bei euch ausgebaut
ist, natürlich noch jemand, der sich
mit Storage und
Virtualisierung auskennt. Das sind
alles drei Schwerpunkte,
mit denen du komplett eine Position
füllen kannst. Je nachdem,
wie viel es gibt und wie tiefgreifend
denn wirklich erforderlich ist. Schwierig!
Also, ich würde
mich nicht darauf bewerben. Was anderes kann ich nicht sagen.
Und ich muss auch mal betonen,
das sagt nichts darüber aus,
ob das ein guter oder schlechter Arbeitgeber
ist. Sondern einfach nur meine
Erste Eindruck von der Stellenanzeige und ich finde
ihn nicht gut. Ja, mehr fällt
mir da jetzt nicht zu ein, was
ich noch sagen könnte an
Tipps. Ja, ich glaube das mit dem
First Level ist schon mal ein guter
ein guter Step,
wenn man das so nicht reinschreibt.
Ach ja, aber,
aber, wenn ihr das jetzt nur
rausnehmt,
damit sich dann einer
drauf bewirbt,
und ihr setzt den dann trotzdem in First Level
Support, dann ist der innerhalb von einer Probezeit
wieder weg. Das kann ich jetzt schon sagen.
Also, nicht nur rausnehmen,
der sollte das dann auch nicht machen müssen.
Nicht
T-Baden, nicht T-Baden.
Ja, gibt es.
Wenn interne Infrastruktur
nicht der Fokus ist, sollte man vielleicht
ein paar Anforderungen komplett rausnehmen.
Wenn das
einfach nur da ist und keinen juckt,
dann sucht man auch niemand explizit
dafür.
Vielleicht sollte man, also, insgesamt
ist das Aufgabenfeld viel zu groß.
Das ist ja wirklich alles.
Ja.
Wenn einer zwei Jahre Erfahrung hat, erkennt er
sich vielleicht ganz brauchbar mit Linux aus,
aber nicht mit dem ganzen Zeug.
Zumal auch, das ist halt das Ding,
das Interesse der Leute
oftmals da komplett
entgegengesetzt läuft. Ja, jemand, der
sich super für, sagen wir jetzt
mal hier, Windows, Microsoft
Zeug interessiert, der hat
meistens nicht viel Plan von Linux, Kubernetes.
Deswegen ist es auch schwierig
jemanden zu finden, weil
irgendwo muss sich das so mit den persönlichen Interessen ja decken.
Ich würde tatsächlich
lieber, und wenn ihr einfach nur jemanden sucht,
ihr könnt auch zwei, drei
Stellenanzeigen machen,
ja, da bewirbt
sich dann vielleicht jemand drauf, der richtig Plan
in Linux hat und ihr stellt fest, ey, der passt richtig
gut bei uns hin.
Passt.
Fällt dann der ganze Windows-Krampel weg, okay.
Aber,
da findet man wenigstens welche.
Okay, der TÜV.
Ne, Moment, wir müssen
noch den Entry, das
interessiert mich jetzt, was das hier ist. Guck mal, die haben
das widerspricht sich ja schon im
Titel, guck mal, die haben hier
die suchen ein Entry-Level
Expert.
Falls das hier
die Skills-Stufe ist, ja.
Vielleicht ist das auch ein Entry-Level
IT-Architekt,
der für Expert-Labs
aber, was auch immer Expert-Labs ist, also
das ist aber unglücklich geschrieben,
weil man kann da, und das ist auch meine
erste Intention gewesen, was ich da rein
interpretiert habe, zu sagen, wir suchen ein
Entry-Level, IT-Architekt
Expert,
was auch immer Labs dann bedeutet,
aber Entry-Level und Expert
ist immer so ein Ding, das klingt irgendwie ein bisschen komisch zusammen.
Okay, sind bei IBM am
Start.
Let's Create ist eine Vision, die du
verbindest mit Spaß
an Teamwork und moderner Technologie.
Das ist so ein typisches,
das ist so ein typischer Intro-Satz, der
rauskommt, wenn die
Marketingabteilung und die
Personalabteilung anfängt,
Stellenanzeigen zusammenzuschreiben.
Ach, Expert-Labs ist quasi die Abteilung.
Ah ja, also sie suchen ein
Entry-Level IT-Architekt, okay.
Und die Kollegen in IBM
Expert-Labs, hier sieht man es ja, okay,
tun exakt das.
Your Role and Responsibilities.
Kundenprobleme
zu identifizieren, zu durchdringen.
Hyper-Gadget
und zu lösen ist für dich
eine spannende Herausforderung.
Moderne IT und
die innovativsten
Werkzeuge begeistern dich.
Kommt drauf
an, was sie darunter
verstehen. 50 Bewerbungen
sind schon ordentlich viel.
Zumal wir heute in einer Zeit leben,
wo viele
sehr gefragt sind.
Du hast
mindestens
ein kleines Problem.
Viele suchen
nicht unbedingt
händeringend Juniorstellen,
sondern Leute, die ein bisschen Erfahrung haben.
Da kannst du jetzt nichts für.
Aber das ist so.
Gerade bei
Advanced- und Seniorjobs
herrscht extremer Mangel.
Was nicht heißt,
dass es keine Stellen
für Juniorleute gibt.
Aber vom Angebot
nachfragedings würde ich sagen, es fehlen
eher die Advanced- und Seniorleute.
Auf der anderen Seite
kann ich zu deiner Bewerbung nichts sagen.
Ich bin auch kein Personaler.
Ich bin auch niemand, der das aus Personalsicht
einschätzen könnte.
Ich kann nur sagen, mir gefällt es.
Das heißt auch lange nicht, dass der Personalabteilung gefällt,
wenn mir das gefällt.
Eine Sache, die tatsächlich immer gut ankommt,
ist Gitterprojekte.
Beziehungsweise falls du
irgendwelche
Sachen online hast,
die man sich angucken kann,
ist das sicherlich auch nice.
Wer weiß, was du da schon gebaut hast.
Also Github
ist sehr beliebt bei Entwicklerstellen.
Geht sogar so weit,
dass bestimmt
der ein oder andere heutzutage sagt,
wenn sich ein Entwickler bewirbt ohne Github-Link,
guck ich es mir gar nicht an.
Gibt es bestimmt welche.
Also Github-Profil sollte auf jeden Fall
rein.
Ansonsten, ich kann dir leider auch keinen,
ich würde dir gerne irgendeinen ultimativen
Tipp geben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also eine Sache, die sicherlich hilft ist,
ich weiß nicht, wie du dich bewirbst,
ob es mehr oder weniger
online mit
Upload sie jetzt hier
ihre Bewerbung ist.
Auch wenn das viele Unternehmen anbieten,
ich glaube,
das muss ich so sagen,
weil ich es selbst nicht ausprobiert habe,
in letzter Zeit.
Ich glaube,
dass es nicht verkehrt ist,
anstelle sich
bei 50
random Unternehmen
nur mit Lebenslauf zu bewerben,
gerade wenn der Lebenslauf nur nach 15 ist,
es ist vielleicht besser,
sich 5
rauszusuchen
und ein individuelles Intro,
also ein individuelles Anschreiben
noch mitzuschicken.
Wenn du dir 5 Stück raussuchst,
die du Bock hast,
dich ein bisschen schlau machst über die
und dann ein gut geschriebenes Anschreiben
noch mitschickst,
gerade wenn du jetzt nicht den
den super herausstechendsten Lebenslauf hast,
kannst du somit bestimmt persönlich Punkte sammeln.
Ansonsten,
ich kann dir keine großartigen Tipps geben.
Daten, Algorithmen und Automatisierung
sind für dich keine Mysterien,
sondern wertvoll.
Wer hat diesen Satz wieder geschrieben,
IBM?
Das ist ja
so ein bescheuerter Satz.
Ist das eine Chat-GPT
Stellenanzeige oder was?
Das ist so ein...
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass es eine Chat-GPT Anzeige ist.
Ich glaube, das ist was rauskommt,
wenn Marketing und Personalabteilung
eine Technikstelle ausschreiben und keine Ahnung haben,
um was es da geht. Whatever.
Dann packe diese Themen
Dann packe
diese Thema mit uns an
und starte deine Karriere
bei einem weltweiten Technologie-Champion.
IBM hat jetzt nicht unbedingt den Ruf
so super krass zu sein noch.
Nicht, dass sie vereinzelt
auch coole Sachen rausgebracht haben,
aber weiß nicht, ob IBM
noch so die...
das Ding ist,
was die Leute damit verbunden haben.
Früher glaube ich nicht.
Eine familiäre Atmosphäre.
Alter, das ist IBM.
Das ist eines der größten Technikläden überhaupt.
Die haben keine familiäre Atmosphäre.
Das ist Business Enterprise
extrem. Wette ich mit euch.
Das ist so...
Oldschool
Business-Kram. Enterprise.
IBM. Da ist sicherlich
nichts mit familiärer Atmosphäre.
Und inklusive...
Was? Und inklusive...
Das ergibt überhaupt...
Was ist das für ein Satz, man?
So, das ist die letzte Stellenanzeige,
die wir uns heute angucken.
Und die ich gerade aufgemacht habe,
weil sonst komme ich nicht hinterher.
Was ist das für ein Satz?
Eine familiäre Atmosphäre
und inklusive Kultur?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur aus dem Englischen
übersetzt.
Sodass sie eben very inclusive und sowas sind.
Das ist einfach nur
wir übersetzt, was so in Deutsch keiner...
In Deutsch würde man schreiben,
jeder ist willkommen oder irgendwie sowas.
Oder ein
inclusive...
Aber das wird man so normalerweise.
Mit einem Growth Mindset.
So wie Freiraum für deine eigenen kreativen Ideen.
Nur es läuft ein gezieltes Onboarding-Programm.
Diese besteht aus verschiedenen Komponenten.
Nationalen...
Beziehungsweise Hybrid...
Okay, da geht es richtig ab.
Übrigens, ich habe es ja öfter schon gesagt,
ich finde es jedes Mal merkwürdig,
wenn eine der Vorteile ist,
sie werden richtig eingearbeitet.
Ich bin der Meinung, eine ordentliche
Einarbeitung sollte im ureigenen
Interesse das Arbeitgeber
liegen, dass du für dein Geld,
was er dir ja auch vom ersten Tag an bezahlen muss,
auch was machen kannst.
Wenn die dich nicht richtig
einarbeiten, dann sind die
selber dran schuld, dass sie Geld zum Fenster
rausschmeißen. Ja, ich weiß, es gibt genug
Läden, wo das nicht passiert. Wo du
hingesetzt wirst und es wird gesagt, ey, mach
halt einfach mal. Aber die sind dumm.
Die sind richtig...
Die sind absolute Pepega. Also ich finde, dass
hier sollte eigentlich jeder, der irgendwie normal
tickt im Kopf, machen seine
Leute ordentlich einarbeiten.
Also eine aufmaßlich technische fachliche
Ausbildung kombiniert mit direkten Hands-on
Tätigkeit bei unseren Kunden. What?
Was sucht ihr nochmal?
Moment!
Bist du dann jemand, der zu Leuten
hinfährt und ihr Storage-System updatet
oder so? Bist du dann so jemand,
wie der eine, der bei uns den
USB-Stick in den
Fahrstuhlschacht geschmissen hat von IBM?
So ein
Vor-Ort-Service-Typ oder wie?
Liest sich ein bisschen so.
Bei uns auf der alten
Arbeit war mal ein
IBM-Service-Typ da. Der hatte auch
eine Hands-On-Tätigkeit bei uns durchzuführen.
Der hatte nämlich einen USB-Stick
dabei und sollte damit unser
Storage-System updaten.
Und dem ist der
USB-Stick aus der Hand gefallen beim
Aussteigen aus dem Fahrstuhl.
Und da ist der USB-Stick genau in
die Lücke gefallen zwischen
Stockwerk und Fahrstuhl. So diese
kleine Lücke, die entsteht bei einem Fahrstuhl,
wenn die Tür aufgeht. So unten da, wo die Tür
ist. So dieser Zentimeter.
Ist der USB-Stick reingefallen,
den Fahrstuhlschacht runter
und damit
nicht genug unten in die
Öl-Pfanne.
Das konnten dann erst irgendwie am
nächsten Montag oder so der Hausmeister rausholen.
Aber eins muss man den Leuten bei IBM sagen,
die waren tatsächlich da sehr erfinderisch.
Die haben
dann in Israel angerufen,
also viele
Storage-Systeme von IBM, die hat IBM ja
auch nur eingekauft und
anscheinend saßen da einige
Entwickler in Israel. Die haben in Israel
angerufen und
da war glaub ich irgendwie Feiertag oder so oder
Wochenende, frag mich nicht.
Oder schon Wochenende, wegen dem Zeitunterschied
irgendwie so. Und da ist dann noch einer dort
in Israel zurück auf die Arbeit gefahren
und hat ihm dann irgendwie
per securem E-Mail
Anhang auf seinen Laptop
die für uns gepatchte Firmware
geschickt, dass er die sich da super
advancedes Zeug des Abends hingekriegt.
Und wir waren dann nur dabei
zum damaligen, ich hab da ein Video übrigens drüber gemacht,
wer sich das genau angucken will hier.
Das hier.
Also wer es ausführlich wissen will, kann sich
das hier angucken.
Wir haben dann nur dabei gesessen
und mussten zugucken.
Ja, der USB-Stick hätte
ein Agilending gebraucht.
Dein Aufgang. Was?
Bring your full self
to work.
Ihr wisst nicht, was ihr schreibt,
Leute.
Denn wir wollen dich so wie du bist.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, Leute.
Das wollt ihr nicht.
Ich weiß das genau, dass ihr das nicht wollt.
Ihr glaubt vielleicht, dass ihr das wollt.
Ihr wollt das aber definitiv
nicht.
Das ist so,
wie wenn Leute sagen so
Ja, fühl dich ganz wie zu Hause.
Das ist so ein Spruch, der gern bei irgendwelchen Filmen
und so kommt. Fühlt euch ganz wie
zu Hause und dann würdest du dich aufs
Sofa setzen und erstmal die Hose ausziehen.
Der meint das auch nicht wortwörtlich.
Du entwickelst ein tiefgreifendes
Verständnis. Boah, jetzt das. Alter,
das hört ja gar nicht mal auf, dieses IBM-Ding hier.
Das will ich mir nicht alles durchlesen.
Also, keine Ahnung.
IBM. Komisch übersetzte
Stellenanzeige.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht übel.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck, wahrscheinlich.
Gar nicht übel.
Ich habe nichts von Homeoffice
oder Remote gelesen.
Home on Weekends.
Wait a minute.
Selbstverständlich bin ich
Home on Weekends. Wo denn sonst?
Travel, wie ihr könnt.
Das gibt es nicht.
Da hätte ich schon mal
keinen Bock drauf, wenn Travel auch
Weekends und so
mit einbezieht. Es sei denn, ihr bezahlt. Super krass.
Wie kann man denn
eine Ausbildung machen, die nicht staatlich anerkannt ist?
Da hast du doch keine Ausbildung gemacht.
Da hast du ja irgendein Codecamp besucht oder so.
Okay, ja, das ist
irgendwie sowas. Nee, das...
Wie lange geht denn das? Zwei Wochen oder so?
Einen Monat?
Ja, dann wundert es mich nicht,
dass das Interesse
sich in Grenzen hält.
Da gucken in Deutschland immer noch
viele drauf, dass du eine
abgeschlossene Ausbildung hast.
Als Physi oder Fachinformatiker,
wenn du
gerade Junior
Quereinsteiger, ohne groß was
vorzuzeigen, ist glaube ich nicht einfach.
In
Stellanzeigen wird auch viel gelabert,
wenn der Tag lange ist. Also du hast mit
der Ausbildung auf jeden Fall deutlich bessere
Chancen, als wenn man nur
einen Codecamp besucht hat.
Und jetzt
ist tatsächlich eine ziemlich gute Gelegenheit
noch für dieses Jahr, sich einen Ausbildungsplatz zu suchen.
Die
fangen erst nach den ersten neunten an.
Die sind jetzt
viele am gucken noch. Also du hast
gerade mit sowas, das ist eine
super Sache für eine Bewerbung,
als, ähm, macht
sich bestimmt super in der Bewerbung als
Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung.
An String erinnern, ja, habe ich gerade.
Also,
da hast du denke ich
gute Chancen, eine Ausbildungsstelle zu finden.
DevOps Engineer
Kubernetes. Ups.
Smart Clip.
EdTech
Entwicklungseinheit der
RTL. Aha.
Die Shopping-
Ne, das war ProSieben, glaube ich.
Ich musste das mal gucken, das war
der schlimmsten Fernsehsendung
ever.
Die Shopping Queen, so ein Schrott.
Okay, wenigstens muss ich dafür keine Gebühren
bezahlen. Unsere
proprietäre Werbetechnik
ist auf spezielle Bedürfnisse von Europäern.
Okay, bla bla bla.
Das müssen wir nicht lesen.
Smart TV Clip.
Okay.
Ich finde, das sieht aus wie eine Webseite,
die sagt, ich möchte ein bisschen
so aussehen wie Apple, ohne Apple zu sein.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Das hat ein bisschen was davon.
Ja, natürlich, immer super, super
glückliche Leute. Ja, so gucke ich auch immer,
wenn ich mir Werbung angucken muss.
Aber, muss sagen, es ist eine
cleane Webseite, ja.
Ist gut gemacht.
Auch wenn ich ja persönlich
dieses geänderte
Scrollverhalten im Desktop echt nicht ab kann.
Auf Twitter sind die
auch. Okay, guck mal.
Sind wohl doch nicht auf
Twitter. Sind sie denn
auf LinkedIn am Start?
Auf LinkedIn sind sie da, okay.
Okay, DevOps Engineer.
Bist du Teil unseres System Operation Teams?
Du bist verantwortlich für die weiterhin
Automatisierung und Betrieb unserer Infrastruktur. Ja, gut.
Passt ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass die meisten
DevOps Engineers ehemalige
Server-Admins sind, ist das
thematisch auch irgendwie ganz passend.
Dabei arbeitest du im engen Austausch
mit den Entwicklungsteams. Dich erwartet
bei uns hervorragende technische
Kollegen, von denen du lernen
kannst. Wir fokussieren uns auf Automatisierung
und halten mehr von
Moment, was? Wir fokussieren uns
auf Automatisierung und halten mehr
von Latest als von
LTS.
Das ist eine gewagte
Aussage,
die ich ganz cool finde.
Die vielleicht im Business Enterprise
Umfeld ein bisschen fragwürdig ist.
Was aber auch heißt, Latest
Leute, Arch by the way.
Arch Linux direkt auf den Server
drauf. Bäm.
Scheiß drauf.
Das muss Schmerzen verursachen.
Und wir stehen total auf Open Source.
Deine Position
in unserem Team. Konzipiere
und automatisiere Entwicklerplattformen
für schnelles, funktionales
Feedback, hohe qualitative Ergebnisse
und maximale. Leute, ich habe legit
keine Ahnung, was die von mir wollen.
Versteht ihr das, was die von mir wollen?
Oder von uns
wollen? Konzipiere und
automatisiere Entwicklerplattformen.
Irgendein Low-Code, No-Code
Geschiss, oder was?
Für schnelles, funktionales
Feedback, hohe qualitative
Ergebnisse, maximale. Was wollt
ihr mir mit dem Satz überhaupt sagen?
Also unter der Entwicklerplattform
verstehe ich, unter anderem gibt es
verschiedene Definitionen davon.
Im Kontext von dieser Anzeige könnte
ich mir unter einer Entwicklerplattform sowas
vorstellen, wie man hat einen
Kubernetes Cluster
und auf dem testen die Entwickler
ihre Software. Allerdings sollen sie das
möglichst eigenständig machen können.
Das heißt, du baust irgendwelche Deployment Pipelines,
irgendwelche Dinger, dass die relativ schnell sehen,
ob Tests klappen, Tests fehlen,
irgendeine neue Testumgebung anlegen
über irgendeinen Bot oder sowas,
dass sie schnell deployen können, gucken,
wie ihre neuen Sachen aussehen. Sowas stelle ich mir unter
Entwicklerplattformen fest.
Ansonsten ist der Satz
echt...
Keine Ahnung.
Das kann alles sein und nichts...
Ja, das ist ja sowas, was
ich gerade versucht habe zu beschreiben. Also quasi
eine Internal Developer Plattform.
Binde moderne Tools an DevOps Pipelines
unter der Beachtung der
funktionalen Sicherheit an.
Also wisst ihr was ich witzig finde?
Das hier ist so übelst
lässig und cool und nice
geschrieben und hier unten ist krasser Business Talk
angesagt. So als hätten das
und das zwei komplett unterschiedliche
Leute geschrieben.
Binde moderne Tools an DevOps Pipelines
unter Beachtung der funktionalen Sicherheit an.
Begleite unsere Teams auf unserer
DevOps Journey.
Leute, meint ihr,
die sind agil
wake-upped?
Oder brauchen die noch einen agilen
wake-up-call
und das passende Landing
für ihre Use Cases?
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Begleite unsere Stärkung
und Softwareentwicklung. Trage
unmittelbar zur Verbesserung einer hochmodellen
Infrastruktur auf der Grundlage von Kubernetes
und Cloud Hyperscaling.
Endlich! Da habe ich heute den ganzen Tag
drauf gewartet,
dass einer mit Hyperscaler um die Ecke kommt.
Ja, ich erzähle es euch monatelang jetzt schon.
Cloud-Anbieter sind out, Hyperscaler sind in,
obwohl es genau das gleiche ist.
Endlich! RTL!
Wo muss erst RTL kommen?
Schütze und sichere unsere Systemumgebung.
So was wie Backstage. Ja, kann sein.
Ja, vermutlich
sowas.
Mindestens fünf Jahre Berufserfahrung.
Da könntet ihr ja mal zumindest, also fünf
Jahre könnten wir vielleicht schon eine Seniorstelle
draus machen, wenn man auf solche Sachen
steht, ja. Letztendlich ist wichtig,
was gemacht wird, was bezahlt wird, ob das Senior
Forschung ist, vollkommen wurscht.
DevOps Engineering, Infrastruktur,
Code, Docker, Kubernetes in Linux.
Cloud-Kenntnisse.
Idealerweise AWS und Google Cloud.
Alter, könnte ich mich direkt bewerben hier.
Ich kenne mich mit allem aus, was die haben wollen.
Erfahrungen mit Shell-Skripting, Greylock, Grafana,
Prometheus, Python, Jenkins. Ey, bam!
Let's go! Ich gehe zur Erde.
Nein, ich gehe nicht zur Erde. Ich bleibe da, wo ich bin.
Ownership, Eigeninitiative,
Selbstmanagement, Bereitschaft
stetig weiterzuentwickeln.
Fokus auf
Effizienz und Qualität.
Leute, wir wissen alle,
was ist Quality?
Ihr wisst es genauso gut
wie ich. Quality is
Destiny, haben wir gelernt bei
Amazon
war das, glaube ich, sogar.
Unser Ansatz, wir werden von spannenden Projekten
angetrieben. Die Freiraum
für persönliche Gestaltung und Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten.
Wir sind stolz darauf, die neuesten Technologien
einzusetzen, um an der Spitze zu
bleiben. Darunter Node.js,
C++. Okay, wir fangen erst mal
mit zwei Technologien an, die jeweils
schon, keine Ahnung, 30
Jahre alt sind und
ähm
15 Jahre alt sind.
Und dann kommt Jenkins, ja.
Skala, Python,
SQL, TypeScript,
JavaScript, React, Docker, Kubernetes,
AWS, Google Cloud und viel mehr. Okay.
Einfach mal alles reingeschmissen.
Tools und Ausrüstung. Wir versorgen dich mit
selbstjahres Equipment, egal ob du Mac,
Windows oder Android bist.
Aha.
Sehr gut. Freie Betriebssysteme
Auswahl frei. Sehr
sehr nice.
Finde ich extrem gut.
Flexible Arbeitsumgebung.
Von der Möglichkeit Remote zu arbeiten
überein auf dem
Honor System based Ansatz für die
Ist das sowas wie Skill based Matchmaking?
Für Arbeitszeiten?
Ich glaube, die wollen uns damit
sagen,
dass man den Leuten vertraut,
so nach dem Motto, die haben alle genug Ehre
nicht zu bescheißen.
Ja, Vertrauensarbeit, sowas, genau.
Unsere neueste Option für eine
4-Tage-Woche. Wissen wir, wie wichtig die
kontinuierliche Entwicklung
die Investition war.
Wir bieten vielfältige Werke,
was wir darüber hinaus bieten. Wir kümmern uns um unsere
deshalb bieten wir attraktive Sozialleistungen
wie Zuschüsse in Deutschland.
Kostenloses RTL plus
Premium Abonnent.
Das habe ich unbedingt gebraucht.
Vergünstigungen durch
Corporate Benefits.
Erlebnisreiche Firmen-Events und vieles
mehr.
Werde Teil unseres hochmotivierten Teams.
Okay, Chat.
Auch wenn ich RTL jetzt nicht unbedingt
nicht der größte RTL
Fan bin. Ich muss sagen,
vielleicht auch,
weil das mein Spezialgebiet
hier alles ist.
Ich muss sagen, es ist die beste
Stellenanzeige heute gewesen.
Was sagt ihr?
Chatge.
Mittel.
Geschmackssache.
Für mich war es die beste heute.
Oder bundesweit im Homeoffice.
Die Tätigkeit ist so nichtssagend.
Naja, ich finde, man kann sich schon
ganz gut ein Bild davon machen.
Die wirklich
konkreten Sachen fehlen jetzt
natürlich.
Aber wenn das hier das ist, was ich reininterpretiere,
passt das
zum Rest.
Es geht im Endeffekt darum, dass Software-Entwickler
ihre Arbeit möglichst gut erledigen können.
Also genau das, was eigentlich ein DevOps-Engineer
machen sollte.
Vor zwei Jahren hast du gesagt, analoges Fernsehen
soll sterben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das und wie ich das gesagt habe,
aber ich hätte damit keine Probleme,
weil ich konsumiere eigentlich kein normales Fernsehen
mehr.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass ich nicht für sowas arbeiten würde.
Wenn die Bezahlung stimmt.
Und ich was suchen würde, was ich nicht mache.
Weil, was juckt's
mich?
Was mit analogem Fernsehen ist.
Also, ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Für mich war das heute die beste Stellenanzeige.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns
jetzt die letzte Stellenanzeige an für heute.
Und zwar, mal gucken, ob der TÜV Nord
das heute noch
toppen kann.
Die Webseite ist schon mal ganz merkwürdig
formatiert.
Das Logo ist auch kaputt.
Ist das hier auch kaputt?
Ne.
Naja, das ist wahrscheinlich, weil ich es geblockt habe.
Das TÜV
Logo ist geblockt.
Dann gucken wir uns das hier an.
Hier geht's.
Wobei ich bei beidem...whatever.
Okay, Stellen, TÜV,
IT, TÜV,
Informationstechnik, in ersten Anstellung
unbefresset, flexible Absprache.
Wie...
Also, das Intro von
dieser Stellenanzeige
ist ja mal ein Musterbeispiel
in, wie kann ich
mit möglichst uninteressanten
Sachen möglichst viel Platz füllen, oder?
Die erste Seite
komplett voll mit nicht komplett
unwichtigen Sachen, aber viel zu voll, man.
Was wir dir bieten?
Wir bieten dir einen sicheren Arbeitsplatz,
ein tarifgeschütztes Gehalt,
was auch heißt,
nicht so super viel.
Kann gut und schlecht sein.
Erstmal ist es gut, wenn es einen Tarifvertrag
gibt,
der oftmals für außertarifliche Sachen
zwar nicht verpflichtend ist,
aber sich oftmals orientiert dran wird.
Ja, so nach dem Motto, okay, es gab jetzt für die
Tarifverträge so
irgendwie keine 4% Erhöhung, das kriegen die anderen
auch. Ist immer gut, wenn es sowas gibt.
Unsere Homeoffice und Teilzeitangebote
unterstützen dich dabei,
deine Berufs...ja.
Gut, dass ihr es schreibt, würde mich natürlich interessieren,
ob das nicht nur gesagt ist, um es zu sagen,
oder auch wirklich dann so
gelebt wird, wie man schon sagt.
Okay, bla bla bla.
ÖPNV-Anmeldung.
Wir fördern
unsere Beschäftigung...
Okay, was du bei uns
bewegst, du entwickelst IT-Security-Standards
der Zukunft und bist zuständig
für die Erstellung, Bewertung und Präsentation
von Spezifikationen für IT-Systeme
und Komponenten der Zukunft.
Klingt jetzt irgendwie
super langweilig?
Ich meine, man ist ja auch
IT-Sicherheitsexpert, Schwerpunkt
Konformitätsprüfung und technische
Spezifikation. Das klingt allein
schon, der Titel dieser Stelle oder der
Name der Stelle klingt nach
Bürokratie-Overload-as-fuck.
Ähm,
das klingt
so ein bisschen nach Sesselfurzerstelle.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es anders beschreiben soll.
Dabei unterstützt du Behörden,
Hersteller sowie Betreibungsumfeld der
IT-Sicherheit und Digitalisierung.
Zudem arbeitest du in Einschlägen, Gremien
und verbe...boah, what the fuck,
Alter. Das klingt auf jeden Fall
nach nix für mich.
Du verantwortest die Prüfung und Bewertung
von Sale of the Art IT-Produktensystemen
nach anerkannten Sicherheitskriterien.
Okay. Ich glaube, auf sowas
muss man der richtige Typ für sein und
Bock drauf haben. Dann ist das super nice,
das Beste, was es gibt. Aber für mich
ist das nix. Tatsächlich, das
muss man ihnen lassen, richtig? Relativ
spezifisch, um was es geht. Das ist ein großer
Pluspunkt, ja?
Da habt ihr recht.
Hochschulabschluss? Warum zum Teufel
brauchst du dafür einen Master?
Okay. Warum
brauchst du dafür jetzt
einen Hochschulabschluss,
um das zu machen?
Es schließt sich mir jetzt noch nicht, aber wenn sie
wollen, dann wollen sie.
Fortgeschrittene Kenntnisse in der IT-Sicherheit,
Erfahrung im Programmieren, zum Beispiel
Python, Java. Ja.
Mit Git und GitLab.
Da programmier ich auch immer.
Und in der Kryptographie.
Man kann sagen, wer schreibt denn das
noch mit PH?
Der TÜV.
Weißt du, wer die Stellenanzeige geschrieben hat?
Idealerweise
Erfahrung im Bereich
Requirements Engineering oder Spezifikation
Technik Anforderungen.
Haha.
Ja, jetzt weiß ich auch,
warum du studiert haben musst.
Für XML.
Analytisches
Arbeiten, Teamkreis und Kommunikationsvermögen,
sicheres Englisch in Wort und Schrift
sowie Reisebereitschaft.
Dann freuen wir uns auf deine
aussagekräftige Bewerbung.
Boah.
Also für mich
wäre es nix.
Man scheitert ja allein schon hier
daran. Ich habe keinen Master oder
keinen Doktor oder sonst was.
Ähm.
Boah, ne.
Ich hoffe, es ist gut bezahlt.
Man weiß es
nicht genau.
Also mich
macht es jetzt nicht so.
So heiß die Stellenanzeige.
Bachelor
war mit. Ist egal, habe ich auch nicht.
Ähm.
Tja.
Ich glaube, wenn man auf
sowas steht, ist das die geilste Stelle
ever. Ich stehe
nicht auf sowas. Mehr kann
ich dazu jetzt nicht sagen.
So Chat, ich hoffe, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Genug
Stellenanzeigen für heute. Heute waren wir aber
fleißig, müssen wir sagen. Ich glaube, so viele
Stellenanzeigen wie heute, haben
wir noch in keinem anderen Stream durchgekriegt.
Das waren bestimmt,
keine Ahnung, 12, 13 Dinger.
Durch, durchgeprügelt.
Naja, ich glaube, ich habe auch
sinnvoll was gesagt
zu jeder.
Die Gehälter beim TÜV sind auch nicht insane.
Na gut, ja. Wundert
mich auch nicht.
Es klang jetzt auch nicht wie an irgendeiner Stelle, die super
krass bezahlt wird, also.
Morgen normaler Stream. Jo, ganz normal.
Morgen früh, wie immer. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
wann es genau losgeht.
Entweder um 9 oder um 10, je nachdem,
ob ich da vor eine Runde rennen gehe oder nicht.
Ich habe jetzt
die gesamte letzten,
die gesamte, ohne Mist, ich glaube, ich habe
die letzten 14 Tage
nicht einen Tag
mal richtig Pause
gemacht. Wobei, das stimmt
nicht. Ich glaube,
ich glaube, letzten Sonntag.
Doch, letzten Sonntag habe ich mich mal
ausgeruht.
Ich bin ansonsten jeden Tag
rennen gewesen oder Fahrrad fahren.
Das ist eine super nice Abwechslung.
Weil, wenn dir
es im Bein ein bisschen weh tut,
vom Rennen, und du den nächsten Tag nicht
rennen gehen willst, fährst du
einfach Fahrrad.
Das belastet ganz andere Regionen.
Und einen Tag danach,
und irgendwie hilft es auch ein bisschen dazu, dass sich die Beine
wieder dann besser anfühlen.
Und, also an den Stellen, die man braucht
zum Rennen. Und am Tag später
gehe ich dann wieder rennen. Warum?
Um so lange keine Videos.
Das ist eine gute
Frage.
Irgendwie hatte ich in letzter Zeit nicht so
den Zug dazu.
Läuft die
Cringe Show schon? Keine Ahnung. Ich gucke ESC
nicht. Ich weiß weder, wer für uns
antritt, noch
was da sonst so
abgeht.
Juckt mich null.
Es, übrigens, Tradekost
scheitert
nicht an keinen Themen. Für mich
sind es nur Videos.
Ich habe eine riesig lange Liste, habe ich schon
oft genug erwähnt, an Themen.
Stehen auch ganz viele Sachen, die ich euch
versprochen habe, noch aus. Zum Beispiel,
dass wir uns zusammen mal meine Bewerbung angucken.
Aber ich hatte nicht so
den Zug dazu.
In letzter Zeit.
Hast du Gamescom News gesehen?
Du meinst das mit
der Sicherheitslücke, oder was?
Oder was meinst
du genau? Ja, das
kenne ich. Das kenne ich. Die haben einen auf
Online Solution gemacht. Ja, genau.
Das kenne ich, ja.
Dass sie den Typ, der
gemeldet hat, dass man Kundendaten
abgreifen kann, über ihre Webseite
erstmal angezeigt haben.
Weißt du, ich weiß nicht, wovon du sprichst.
Ja, Leute.
Schön,
dass ihr am Start wart.
Dass so viele so lange dabei waren.
Ich
gehe jetzt auf
Afglo. Bisschen MMO Kreise
machen. Und dann sehen wir uns
morgen früh zum Aufwach-Stream wieder.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
Und danke für die Subs.
Bis dann. See you.